Hello, Office Ladies listeners. We are breaking in before our theme music because we want to tell you something very exciting. Because we found out we are the number one best-selling book, The Office BFFs, on The New York Times' best-seller list. For nonfiction and for ebook, we couldn't have gotten here without you. Thank you, thank you, thank you.
大家好，Office Ladies 听众们。在我们的主题音乐响起之前，我们要打断一下，因为有一件非常让人兴奋的事想告诉大家。我们发现我们的书《The Office BFFs》登上了《纽约时报》畅销书排行榜的第一名。非虚构类和电子书类都是第一。没有你们，我们不可能走到今天。谢谢，谢谢，谢谢你们。
And now on with the show. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories
现在继续我们的节目。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。我们是好朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极版《办公室》重看播客。每周，我们将剖析一集《办公室》，并带来独家幕后故事，
that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office Ladies. Hello, Angela. Hi. Are you ready for us to have a baby today? I mean, whether you're ready or not, it's happening. It sure is. That's kind of how it works.
这些故事只有当时身临其境的两个人才能告诉你。我们是 Office Ladies。你好，安吉拉。嗨。你准备好让我们今天生个孩子了吗？我的意思是，不管你准备好没有，事情就要发生了。确实如此。这正是它的运作方式。
Today is the delivery part two. It is season six, episode 18, written by Charlie Grandy and directed by Harold Ramis. Well, Jenna, I'd love a summary. Here it is, Angie. Cecilia Marie Halpert is born. And this episode follows Jim and Pam's first couple of days as new parents.
今天是分娩（下）。这是第六季第十八集，由查理·格兰迪编剧，哈罗德·雷米斯导演。好吧，珍娜，我想要一个剧情梗概。给你，安吉杰。塞西莉亚·玛丽·哈尔珀特出生了。这一集讲述了吉姆和帕姆作为新手父母的头几天。
Pam struggles to breastfeed and Jim struggles to feel useful, but they are so happy and it's really cute. Meanwhile, back at The Office, Michael tries playing matchmaker by orchestrating a lunch date between Aaron and Kevin. Dwight finds mold in Jim and Pam's kitchen and decides to take care of it.
帕姆努力进行母乳喂养，吉姆努力想让自己显得有用，但他们非常高兴，真的太可爱了。与此同时，回到办公室，迈克尔试图通过撮合艾伦和凯文的午餐约会来扮演红娘。德怀特在吉姆和帕姆的厨房里发现了霉菌，并决定处理掉它。
And Dwight and Angela finalize their baby-making contract. Yep. Their procreation punch card. Get it ready. I love that you saved that. I have it. I put it in our book. I know.
德怀特和安吉拉敲定了他们的生子合同。没错。他们的生育打孔卡。准备好吧。我很高兴你把这个留着。我有。我把它放进我们的书里了。我知道。
Fast fact number one, Pam and Jim's baby is named after my niece. So cute. So the same week that we were shooting this episode, my sister Emily gave birth to her first child, a daughter. It was so crazy. I mean... It's crazy because Pam is pregnant having a baby, but in real life, it was your sister having a baby.
第一条快速冷知识，帕姆和吉姆的孩子是用我侄女的名字命名的。太可爱了。就在我们拍摄这一周，我姐姐埃米莉生下了她的第一个孩子，一个女儿。太疯狂了。我是说……这太疯狂了，因为帕姆怀孕要生孩子，但在现实生活中，是你的姐姐在生孩子。
Literally the day we shot Pam going to the hospital was the day my sister came home from the hospital. That's so crazy. So in my family... What were the text messages like? I was going to say my parents would joke that they had one kid doing it for real and one kid pretending all at the same time.
简直就是我们拍摄帕姆去医院的那天，也是我姐姐出院回家的日子。太疯狂了。所以在我的家里……当时的短信内容是怎样的？我本想说，我的父母会开玩笑说，他们同时有一个孩子在来真的，还有一个孩子在假装。
So my sister had told me ahead of time what they were planning to name their daughter. So I went to the writers and I asked if we could name Pam and Jim's baby after my niece, and they said yes. But you didn't tell your sister that. Oh, no. I didn't tell my parents or my sister.
所以我的姐姐提前告诉我了他们打算给女儿取什么名字。于是我去找编剧，问我们能不能用我侄女的名字来给帕姆和吉姆的孩子命名，他们答应了。但你没告诉你姐姐。哦，没有。我没告诉我父母或我姐姐。
You didn't tell your parents either? I didn't. Oh, my gosh. When did they find out? When it aired. Come on. You kept it a secret that whole time? I did.
你连父母都没告诉？我没有。哦，天哪。他们什么时候发现的？节目播出的时候。拜托。你把这个秘密保守了整整一路？是的。
That is so fun. They must have flipped out. Well, I remember sitting at home that night that the episode aired and I just kept watching the clock. And sure enough, like 30 seconds after it went live, my phone started ringing and it was my sister. And she was just screaming into the phone. I can't believe how good you are at, like,
太有趣了。他们肯定抓狂了。嗯，我记得那天晚上播出的节目里，我坐在家里，一直盯着时钟。果不其然，就在节目上线大约30秒后，我的电话开始响了，是我姐姐。她在电话那头尖叫。我真不敢相信你这么擅长，呃，
just being patient for a surprise. I am horrible at it. I mean, so much so, my daughter was just telling me because we were celebrating her birthday. Right before she would open a gift, I'd be like, now this one, she'd be like, Mom, Mom, I'm about to open it. No hints.
就是对惊喜保持耐心。我在这方面简直糟透了。不仅如此，我女儿刚刚还在告诉我，因为我们在庆祝她的生日。就在她准备拆礼物之前，我会说，现在这个，她会说，妈妈，妈妈，我正要拆呢。别给暗示。
Well, I thought it would be fun to hear from my sister, Emily, what this was like. Oh, my gosh. That'd be great. So she sent in an audio clip. Here's my sister. Aw. So I can remember back when we were watching
好吧，我想听听我姐姐埃米莉讲述当时的感受会很有趣。哦，天哪。那太棒了。所以她发来了一段音频。这是我姐姐。啊。我记得以前我们在看
the episode where Pam and Jim have their baby. I remember thinking ahead of time, like, oh, I wonder what they're going to name the baby. And I wanted to ask Jenna, but we had an agreement ever since the show started that she would never give me any spoilers because I wanted to find out when everybody else did what was going to happen on the show. And so that was kind of like our, I shouldn't say,
帕姆和吉姆生孩子的内集时。我提前在想，哦，不知道他们会给孩子起什么名字。我想问珍娜，但自从节目开播以来，我们有一个约定，就是她绝不能给我任何剧透，因为我想在其他人知道节目里会发生什么的时候才知道。所以这有点像我们的，我该怎么说，
unspoken rule, but that was kind of the agreement that we had from, you know, the day that the show started was that I wasn't going to get any spoilers. I wanted to find out what happened when everybody else found out. So, you know, being a new mom and being sleep deprived, you know, at that time we were watching the office and I was like so excited and anticipation.
心照不宣的规则，但这算是我们从，你知道的，节目开播那天起就有的协议，就是我不会得到任何剧透。我想在其他人发现的时候才知道发生了什么。所以，你知道的，作为一个新手妈妈，睡眠不足，你知道的，那时候我们在看办公室，我非常兴奋和期待。
I'm like, oh, I wonder what it's going to be. And then all of a sudden Jim walked out and he was like Cecilia Marie Helpert. And I was like, oh, being a sleep deprived new mom, it took me a second. And I was like, oh my gosh, that's our daughter's name. Oh my gosh, did they name the baby after our Cecilia Marie? And I like got so excited and like called my sister right away
我想，哦，不知道会是什么名字。然后突然吉姆走出来说，塞西莉亚·玛丽·哈尔珀特。然后我就想，哦，作为一个睡眠不足的新手妈妈，我反应了一会儿，然后我想，哦，天哪，那是我们女儿的名字。哦，天哪，他们是用我们的塞西莉亚·玛丽给孩子命名的吗？我太激动了，马上给姐姐打电话，
and I was like, wait a second. And she just started laughing. And she was like, yeah, is that okay that we did that? And of course I was like, you know, crying and I was like, oh my gosh, that's so cool. And so, you know, after that episode aired, of course, you know, all the articles and everything that came out about how, you know, they named the CC on the show after my CC.
我说，等等。她就笑了起来。她说，是的，我们这么做可以吗？当然，我当时都哭了，我说，哦，天哪，这太酷了。所以，你知道的，那一集播出之后，当然，你知道的，所有关于他们如何用我的cc给节目中的cc命名的文章和其他东西都出来了。
And, you know, we saved all those articles. We put them on my daughter's baby book. And I still remember, you know, for quite some time after that, people were like, oh, do you watch that show at the office? Did you name your baby after Pam and Jim's baby? And I always enjoyed setting people straight. I was like, oh, no, no, no, no, I'm sorry. See Pam and Jim's baby was named after my baby.
而且，你知道的，我们把所有这些文章都存了下来。我们把它们放进我女儿的婴儿纪念册里。我仍然记得，你知道的，在那之后的相当长一段时间里，人们会问，哦，你看那个节目《办公室》吗？你给孩子起的名字是跟帕姆和吉姆的孩子学的吗？我总是很乐意纠正大家。我说，哦，不，不，不，不，不好意思，看帕姆和吉姆的孩子是用我的孩子命名的。
So that was always really fun to do after the show aired. That is so cute. I love that she saved the articles and they're in the baby book. Yeah. Well, I have to say, so my niece, Cece, she is the age that Cece Halpert would be. And whenever we go out together and I'm calling her Cece and people see us together, it like is a real, like,
所以节目播出后做这件事总是觉得很有趣。太可爱了。我喜欢她把文章存下来并放进婴儿纪念册里。是的。好吧，我得说，我的侄女茜茜，她和茜茜·哈尔珀特同龄。每当我们一起外出，我叫她茜茜，人们看到我们在一起，这简直是一场真正的，呃，
mind bender for them. I was gonna say, you didn't think that one through. I didn't think about that part. Yeah. That is so special, though. I just love it. You know, the baby photo that I had on my desk for the rest of the run of the show is a baby photo of my niece Cece when she was a baby.
脑力激荡。我本想说，你当时没考虑周全。我没考虑到那一部分。是的。不过，这真的很特别。我太喜欢了。你知道的，在剧集剩下的拍摄期间，我放在办公桌上的那张婴儿照片，就是我侄女茜茜小时候的婴儿照片。
That is so sweet. So it's like a really special thing in our family. That's a family Easter egg. It really is. But here's another thing that's funny. Cece's dad's name in real life is Dwight. And her grandpa's name is Jim. This is craziness.
太甜了。所以这就像是我们家里一件非常特别的事情。这是一个家族彩蛋。确实是。但还有一件有趣的事。茜茜现实生活中的爸爸叫德怀特。她爷爷叫吉姆。这太疯狂了。
So we've really created something there for that family. So yeah. Aw. Well, Jenna Joya, who worked at NBC Digital, you guys know we've talked to Joya quite a bit as we rewatch the episode. She shared with me that they made a Pam's baby blog website. Oh, yes. I remember.
所以我们确实为那个家庭创造了一些东西。所以，是的。啊。好吧，珍娜·焦亚，曾在 NBC Digital 工作，你们知道的，正如我们重看这集时所说，我们和焦亚聊了很多。她告诉我，他们制作了一个帕姆的婴儿博客网站。哦，是的。我记得。
And she even sent me the birth announcement that they made for the blog. And it showed that on March 4th, 2010, at 9.32 p.m., Pam Halpert made a post introducing Cecilia Marie Halpert, weighing in at seven pounds and two ounces. Aw. Yeah. Isn't that cute? And I'll put that in stories. Well, I remember that they would have me write little things about how baby Cece was doing.
她甚至把他们为博客制作的出生公告发给了我。上面显示，在 2010 年 3 月 4 日晚上 9 点 32 分，帕姆·哈尔珀特发布了一条动态，介绍了塞西莉亚·玛丽·哈尔珀特，体重七磅二两。啊。是的。是不是很可爱？我会把它发到快拍里。好吧，我记得他们会让我写一些关于婴儿茜茜近况的小短文。
It was a way that when Pam was on maternity leave, there was still activity from that character, at least as far as the blog. Yeah. Yeah. Well, the birth announcement was really cute. All right. Fast fact number two is a location breakdown. Jim and Pam give birth at Moses Taylor Hospital, which is a real hospital in Scranton.
这是一种当帕姆在产假期间，该角色仍能保持活跃度的方式，至少就博客而言是这样。是的。是的。好吧，出生公告真的很可爱。好的，第二条快速冷知识是一个取景解析。吉姆和帕姆在摩西·泰勒医院生孩子，这是斯克兰顿的一家真实医院。
But of course, we did not shoot at the real Moses Taylor Hospital. The exterior of the hospital we shot at was St. Joseph Hospital in Burbank, California, but the interiors were built over on our warehouse set. The entire hospital set, the waiting room, the hospital room, the hallways, all of it. I mean, the detail. Amazing. Randy shared with me that they had torn down the Dunder Mifflin New York offices because we don't need them anymore.
但当然，我们并没有在真正的摩西·泰勒医院拍摄。我们拍摄医院外观的地方是加州伯班克的圣约瑟夫医院，但内部是在我们的仓库布景上搭建的。整个医院布景，候诊室，病房，走廊，全都是。我是说，细节。太神奇了。兰德里告诉我，他们拆除了邓德米夫林纽约办公室，因为我们不再需要它们了。
Right. And in their place, they built the hospital. So the other big storyline in this episode involves Dwight destroying Jim and Pam's kitchen. Rather than go destroy someone's house, our set designer, Michael Gallenberg, took photos and measurements of the original location house that we had used for Jim and Pam's house. And then they meticulously recreated the floor plan also on our warehouse set. They built basically two structures. They built a hospital and a house.
没错。并在它们的原址上建造了医院。所以这一集的另一个重大剧情线涉及德怀特破坏吉姆和帕姆的厨房。为了不真的去破坏别人的房子，我们的布景设计师迈克尔·加伦贝格拍摄了我们之前用于吉姆和帕姆家的那栋原址房屋的照片和尺寸。然后他们在我们的仓库布景上细致地重建了平面图。他们基本上建造了两个结构。他们建造了一家医院和一个房子。
Yes. It was constructed by Tim James and decorated by Steve Rothstein. It's funny, Angela, like you said, they were right next to each other. When Isabelle, the character of Isabelle, goes from the hospital to Jim and Pam's house, she really did not have to walk very far. No, just around the corner. We shot those on the same day and it was very easy for her. And when I was going back and forth with Randy about these locations, he told me a very fun tidbit.
是的。它由蒂姆·詹姆斯建造，史蒂夫·罗斯斯坦装饰。好笑的是，安吉拉，就像你说的，它们就在彼此隔壁。当伊莎贝尔这个角色从医院走到吉姆和帕姆家时，她真的不用走多远。没有，就在拐角处。我们是在同一天拍摄的，对她来说非常容易。当我和兰迪就这些取景地来回沟通时，他告诉了我一个非常有趣的内幕。
Angela, do you remember that little kitchen outside of our writer's offices? By the back stairwell? Yeah. Yeah. It wasn't really a kitchen. It was almost just like a pantry kind of thing. It was like a shelf. They'd put food on it.
安吉拉，你还记得我们编剧办公室外面的那个小厨房吗？在后楼梯旁？对。是的。那其实不是厨房。它几乎只是一种茶水间之类的东西。就像是一个架子。他们会把食物放在上面。
It wasn't really a kitchen. No. They had an old refrigerator, but there was not any sink or working plumbing or any appliances. There was, I think, a toaster oven, maybe a microwave. Yeah, yeah. It was kind of a sad kitchen. It was sad. Well, when this script came up, Randy said he saw these beets of Dwight demolishing the Halpert kitchen.
那真的不是厨房。没有。他们有一个旧冰箱，但没有任何水槽、正常工作的管道或任何电器。我想，可能有一个小烤箱，也许还有微波炉。对，对。那是个有点悲伤的厨房。很悲伤。好吧，当这个剧本出来时，兰迪说他看到了德怀特拆毁哈尔珀特厨房的这些片段。
And his, quote, mental wheels started turning. Oh, Randy, he thought, what if we bought enough cabinets for several takes of the Halpert kitchen, but then had enough leftover to remodel and refurbish the writer's kitchen? So he spoke to Michael Gallenberg and Steve Rothstein. And when the episode wrapped over the subsequent weekend, they had a construction crew scheduled to, like, come strike the Halpert kitchen. And that same crew brought that extra cabinetry and flooring to the writer's kitchen, and they completely remodeled it over one weekend.
他的，引述，大脑开始飞速运转。哦，兰迪，他想，如果我们购买了足够拍摄好几次哈尔珀特厨房的橱柜，但随后又剩下了足够改造和翻新编剧厨房的材料呢？于是他跟迈克尔·加伦贝格和史蒂夫·罗斯斯坦谈了谈。当这一集在随后的周末杀青时，他们安排了一支施工队来拆除哈尔珀特厨房。而同一支施工队把那些多出来的橱柜和地板运到了编剧的厨房，并在一个周末里彻底翻新了它。
So when the writers came to work the following Monday, they were greeted by, quote, a spotless pristine and sanitary kitchen with plenty of counter space to lay out their lunch choices. He said the dishwasher that had been in the Halpert kitchen was installed in the adjacent hallway, where there was an existing sink and plumbing. They added a garbage disposal. So after six seasons, the writers had a clean space to keep food, and the PAs had a garbage disposal and dishwasher to wash up. Randy said he cleverly buried the costs in the episode's budget.
所以当编剧们在接下来的星期一上班时，迎接他们的是，引述，一个一尘不染、原始卫生的厨房，有充足的台面空间来摆放他们的午餐选择。他说，原本在哈尔珀特厨房里的洗碗机被安装在相邻的走廊里，那里有现成水槽和管道。他们增加了一个垃圾处理器。所以经历了六季之后，编剧们终于有了一个干净的空间来存放食物，制片助理们也有了垃圾处理器和洗碗机来清洗。兰迪说他巧妙地把这些费用藏在了这一集的预算里。
It was a win-win for everyone. I remember this. I remember this now that you're sharing it. I remember how excited the writers were to have a real kitchen. But I never knew how it came about or anything like that. Randy always was looking out. That is such a great story. It is such a good example of how he was always trying to make every person's life on set a little better however he could.
这对每个人来说都是双赢。我记得这个。现在你分享出来，我想起来了。我记得编剧们能有一个真正的厨房时有多兴奋。但我从来不知道它是怎么来的或者诸如此类的事情。兰迪总是关照大家。这真是一个伟大的故事。这真是一个很好的例子，说明他总是尽其所能地让片场每个人的生活变得更好一点。
All right, fast fact number three, Angela. We had two pretty big guest stars on this show. First up, Sarah Baker as Nurse Josie. She was born in DC, raised in Springfield, Virginia. She studied theater and English at James Madison University. She went on to practice improv at Whole World Improv Theater as both a student and teacher. She continued studying performing at the groundlings after moving to Los Angeles, and she has appeared in numerous films and television shows such as The Campaign,
好的，第三条快速冷知识，安吉拉。我们在这一集中迎来了两位非常重量级的客串明星。首先是饰演若西护士的萨拉·贝克。她出生于华盛顿特区，在弗吉尼亚州斯普林菲尔德长大。她在詹姆斯麦迪逊大学学习戏剧和英语。她后来作为学生和老师在全世即兴剧剧院练习即兴表演。搬到洛杉矶后，她继续在爆笑一箩筐学习表演，并出演了众多电影和电视作品，例如《政坛乾坤》，
starring Will Ferrell, Goliath, Better Things, The Kaminsky Method, and Will and Grace. And she was nominated for a Critics' Choice Award for her guest starring role on Louie. She just crushed it. She was amazing. She was so good. I mean, some of the looks that she gives to Jim and Pam are so good. Her chemistry with John Krasinski was amazing. I know.
由威尔·法瑞尔主演，还有《巨人》、《难黑老妈》、《柯明斯基方法》和《威尔与格蕾丝》。她还凭借在《路易不容易》中的客串演出获得了评论家选择奖提名。她简直演得太棒了。她太惊艳了。她太优秀了。我是说，她给吉姆和帕姆的一些眼神简直太棒了。她和约翰·卡拉辛斯基的化学反应太惊人了。我知道。
I mean, I would just sit there in between them as they were giving their just gentle snarky sass. It was so much fun. And our second big guest star is Lee Kirk as our lactation consultant, Clark. You're husband. My husband. Exactly. So we were engaged to be married when he played Clark, and he is going to come on the show today,
我是说，当他们展现出那种温和带刺的傲娇时，我就会坐在他们中间。太有趣了。我们的第二位大牌客串明星是饰演我们的泌乳顾问克拉克的李·柯克。你的丈夫。我的丈夫。正是如此。所以他扮演克拉克时我们正订婚准备结婚，他今天将来到节目中，
and we're going to get to talk to him all about that experience. He did so great. I can't wait to talk to him. I have a few questions for him. I think our listeners know Lee as a person who makes amazing eggs and coffee. They also know that he's a writer-director. But what you might not know about him is that he did attend the Goodman School for acting in Chicago. So acting in this episode was not too big of a leap for him,
我们将有机会跟他好好聊聊那段经历。他做得太棒了。我等不及要跟他聊聊了。我有几个问题要问他。我想我们的听众都知道李是一个会做好吃的鸡蛋和咖啡的人。他们也知道他是一位编剧兼导演。但你可能不知道的是，他确实在芝加哥古德曼戏剧学校学习过表演。所以在这集中演戏对他的跨度不算太大，
even though ultimately now he is a writer-director. And you know, Lee was supposed to come into the studio with us today. We were so excited, but our daughter woke up not feeling great. So she stayed home from school. He's staying home with her. And we're actually going to have to talk to my own husband, but over a Zoom. But you know what? He's going to be here, and it's going to be super fun.
尽管最终现在他是一名编剧兼导演。你知道的，李本该今天和我们一起进录音室的。我们太兴奋了，但我们的女儿醒来后感觉不太舒服。所以她没去上学，待在家里。他陪她待在家里。我们实际上不得不通过 Zoom 来采访我自己的丈夫。但你知道吗？他会出席的，这将会超级有趣。
I'm just so excited that he's going to be on the show. Yeah. It's going to be kind of cool. All right. Well, we're going to take a break. And when we come back, we'll break down this first part of the episode, and then later we'll talk to Clark. Well, we're back.
我太兴奋他能来参加节目了。是的。这会挺酷的。好吧，我们要休息一下。当我们回来时，我们将剖析这一集的第一部分，稍后我们再和克拉克聊聊。好吧，我们回来了。
Jim went to get himself ice chips because he kind of got a little dizzy there for a minute. He might have passed out a little bit. He might have passed out, yeah. Well, I don't know if you notice when he comes through those automatic doors at 26 seconds. Those are fakie doors. Those were not automatic. Just like our elevator, that's some movie magic for you. Randy Cordray told me that they were operated by our grips who had to pull on cables in unison.
吉姆去给自己拿冰屑了，因为他刚才有点头晕。他可能稍微晕厥了一下。他可能晕厥了，是的。好吧，我不知道你有没有注意到，当他在 26 秒时穿过那些自动门时。那些是假门。它们不是自动的。就像我们的电梯一样，那是属于你们的电影魔法。兰迪·科德雷告诉我，它们是由我们的场务操作的，他们必须齐心协力拉动缆绳。
Each door was being pulled by a different person, and they would get a cue on a walkie-talkie from our first AD who was watching the action live. Well, they did great because you would never know. Never know. They timed it perfectly. Well, Michael is going to arrive with, I think, all the balloons they had in the store that day. I mean, there's so many, and they're huge. And Jenna, he's just going to barge right into the delivery room.
每扇门由不同的人拉动，他们会从正在现场观看动作的第一副导演那里通过对讲机得到一个暗号。好吧，他们干得太棒了，因为你根本看不出来。绝看不出来。他们时机把握得完美无缺。好吧，迈克尔带着，我想，那天店里所有的气球赶到了。我是说，有那么多，而且它们很大。珍娜，他直接闯进产房。
He's not going to knock. He's just going to go right in. Well, I mean, it says family only, so he walked right in. Oh, perfect. He's going to get a real eyeful. You can only hear what's going on in there. The camera doesn't go in. Just Michael.
他不敲门。他就这么直接进去了。好吧，我是说，上面写着仅限家属，所以他就直接走进去了。哦，完美。他可真是大饱眼福了。你只能听到里面发生了什么。摄像机不进去。只有迈克尔。
Did you hear Jim say pull? Yes, I did. The nurses are saying push, and then Jim says pull. We got a fan question from Crystal in Houston, Texas that said, Jenna, as a mom of three, I have to know what you were doing as Pam when you were pushing CC out and Michael walked in. My brain totally goes to stirrups and a hospital gown and, well, any of the other things that might happen in a delivery room. Crystal, this is such a good question. Jenna, what were you doing?
你听到吉姆说拉了吗？是的，我听到了。护士们在喊推，然后吉姆喊拉。我们收到了来自得克萨斯州休斯顿的克里斯特尔的一个粉丝提问，上面写着，珍娜，作为三个孩子的妈妈，我必须知道当茜茜被你生出来而迈克尔走进来时，你在作为帕姆做些什么。我的脑海里完全浮现出产凳、病号服，以及，呃，任何其他可能在产房里发生的事情。克里斯特尔，这个问题太棒了。珍娜，你在做什么？
The door that Steve opens led to a room that was about the size of a small coat closet. So you were just all wedged in there? It was me, John, Sarah Baker, who plays the nurse, and Steve Sox, who was our stand in. He was doing the voice of the doctor, and we were all sitting there like shoulder to shoulder, knee to knee on folding chairs. So you were yelling into the faces of other people. Yes. And I don't know why they built walls onto this room because it wasn't a real room, but they did. Maybe for sound?
史蒂夫打开的那扇门通往一个大约只有小型衣帽间大小的房间。所以你们所有人都挤在那里？里面有我和约翰、饰演护士的萨拉·贝克，还有担任我们替身的史蒂夫·索克斯。他在配医生的声音，我们全都在那儿肩并肩、膝碰膝地坐在折叠椅上。所以你们是在冲着其他人的脸大喊大叫。是的。我不知道他们为什么要在房间里砌墙，因为它不是一个真正的房间，但他们确实砌了。也许是为了隔音？
Oh, maybe so. But we also shot the scene around 7.30 in the morning. It was the very first scene of the day. Well, that's a good way to wake up. It's true. Start yelling now. Also, all of that dialogue that you hear was scripted. We were not just improvising word for word in the script.
哦，也许吧。但我们拍摄这场戏的时间大约是早上 7 点 30 分。那是当天的第一场戏。好吧，这倒是个醒神的好方法。确实如此。现在就开始大喊大叫吧。另外，你听到的所有那些台词都是剧本写好的。我们不仅仅是在剧本里逐字即兴发挥。
Greg shared on the commentary that the part where Michael walks in during Pam's labor, that was a pitch from him. He said that when his wife was having their first child, her college roommate walked into their hospital room, right as his wife was going through the toughest part of her labor, and they were worried that it freaked her friend out. Oh my gosh. He said that she didn't have kids for years. That is crazy. Well, Michael's reaction is that he has to go wash his eyes. And Andy now arrives, and he's really disappointed.
格雷格在随片评论中分享说，迈克尔在帕姆分娩期间闯入的那一部分，是他的一个点子。他说，当他的妻子生第一个孩子时，她大学室友闯进了他们的病房，正好赶上他的妻子经历分娩最艰难的时刻，他们担心这把她的朋友吓坏了。哦，天哪。他说她好多年都不敢生孩子。这太疯狂了。好吧，迈克尔的反应是他得去洗洗眼睛。现在安吉拉到了，他真的很失望。
He was going to give Baby Halpert a framed newspaper of the day she was born. It's really such a sweet gesture. The headline was Spring Has Sprung. Yeah, but that was if she was delivered yesterday. She was a day later than he thought, so now he's going to have to swap it out for today's headline. Which is all about the Scranton Strangler. I mean, it's such a funny joke to me. I just loved it.
他原本打算送给小哈尔珀特一份她出生当天的镶框报纸。这真的是一个非常贴心的举动。头条是“春天已降临”。是的，但那是如果她是昨天出生的话。她比他想象的晚了一天出生，所以现在他不得不把它换成今天的头条。头条全是关于斯克兰顿扼杀魔的。我是说，对我来说这真是一个很好笑的笑话。我太喜欢了。
Well, Jenna Randy shared with us that the images of these prop newspapers were crafted by Phil Shea, and CC's date of birth, according to the newspapers, is Thursday, March 11th, which is curious since the episode originally aired on Thursday, March 4th. And I will point out that the birth announcement made by NBC Digital also says March 4th. Yes, here's what happened. They were originally going to air the delivery part one on March 4th, and then wait a week until March 11th to air delivery part two. But then later, they decided to turn it into a one-hour special episode.
好吧，珍娜，兰迪跟我们分享说，这些道具报纸的图片是由菲尔·谢伊制作的，根据报纸显示，茜茜的出生日期是 3 月 11 日星期四，这很奇怪，因为这一集最初是在 3 月 4 日星期四播出的。我要指出的是，NBC Digital 制作的出生公告上也写着 3 月 4 日。是的，事情是这样的。他们原本打算在 3 月 4 日播出分娩（上），然后等一周直到 3 月 11 日播出分娩（下）。但后来，他们决定把它变成一个一小时的特别集。
Repro. Exactly. But we'd already shot it, and we'd already made all the props, and they couldn't fix it. And we got so much mail about it. About the date? Yes, about, like, wait a second. It's March 4th. Is she born next week?
重做。没错。但我们已经拍完了，所有的道具也都做好了，他们没法修改了。我们为此收到了大量的信件。关于日期的？是的，关于，等一下。今天是 3 月 4 日。她是下周出生吗？
How is this happening? Well, maybe we all have to take a cue from this moment, and don't buy a gift till after the baby's born. Well, you know, one other thing about The Scranton Strangler, I believe this is the very first mention of The Scranton Strangler in the office lore. I think it is as well. On the commentary, they briefly mentioned that they're introducing this idea. Well, we got a fan theory from Elizabeth in Toronto, Canada, who said, Toby is The Scranton Strangler.
这怎么可能发生？好吧，也许我们都得从这个时刻吸取教训，千万别在孩子出生前买礼物。好吧，你知道的，关于斯克兰顿扼杀魔的另一件事，我相信这是《办公室》传说中第一次提到斯克兰顿扼杀魔。我想也是。在随片评论中，他们简短地提到他们正在引入这个概念。好吧，我们收到了来自加拿大安大略省多伦多市的伊丽莎白的一个粉丝理论，她说，托比就是斯克兰顿扼杀魔。
When the headline of the newspaper Andy brought in says Scranton Strangler strikes again, I think it points to Toby because he would have been upset that Pam was having Jim's baby and he took out his anger by strangling someone. Also, Toby is not in the hospital waiting room, which he should have been if he really cared for Pam. So many people think it's Toby. And they think, here's the evidence. That would be the episode I would come back for, Jenna. Toby's trial?
当安吉拉带来的报纸头条写着“斯克兰顿扼杀魔再次袭击”时，我认为这指向了托比，因为他会因为帕姆怀了吉姆的孩子而心烦意乱，于是他通过勒死某人来发泄怒火。此外，托比不在医院候诊室里，如果他真的在乎帕姆的话，他本该在那里的。有这么多人认为凶手是托比。他们觉得，这就是证据。珍娜，那会是我愿意回归的那一集。托比受审？
Yes. Toby on trial and we're all being interviewed? Yeah. Yeah, the whole Dunder Mifflin like bullpen is being interviewed. Well, listen, Toby is not in the hospital waiting room, but a lot of other people are including Phyllis. And she is getting a little annoyed because she's been waiting around for this baby. She's got an ice cream cake in the car.
是的。托比受审，我们所有人都在接受采访？是的。是的，整个邓德米夫林的办公大楼都在接受采访。好吧，听着，托比不在医院候诊室里，但还有很多其他人，包括菲莉丝。她有点生气，因为她一直在等这个孩子。她的车里有一个冰淇淋蛋糕。
What I loved about this moment is that Michael was so annoyed with her for being impatient about Pam once Pam having the baby. He's like, what do you have to do today? And she's like, I have an ice cream cake in my car. And he goes, oh my God, Phyllis, go now. I loved it. Good news. The baby is here.
我最喜欢这个时刻的是，迈克尔对她对帕姆生孩子表现出的不耐烦感到非常恼火。他说，你今天还有什么事要做？她说，我车里有个冰淇淋蛋糕。然后他说，哦，天哪，菲莉丝，快去吧。我太喜欢了。好消息。孩子来了。
Michael's going to celebrate by smoking a cigar in the hospital. The orderly who tells Michael you can't smoke in here was played by Nicholas Day-Clark. I loved this moment. Well, this is going to take us to a very sweet moment. Pam and Jim, they're looking at their beautiful baby girl. They're gazing at each other. They're counting her fingers and her toes. Angela, when you looked at Pam post birth in this moment laying in the bed with Jim,
迈克尔要通过在医院里抽雪茄来庆祝。告诉迈克尔你不能在这里抽烟的那个医院杂役由尼古拉斯·戴-克拉克饰演。我太喜欢这个时刻了。好吧，这将带我们走向一个非常温馨的时刻。帕姆和吉姆，他们正看着他们美丽的宝贝女儿。他们脉脉含情地凝视着彼此。他们在数她的手指和脚趾。安吉拉，当你看到这一刻产后帕姆和吉姆躺在床上的样子时，
did that ring realistic to you? I did not have children when I made this episode. And I just want to say I did not look like that after having my babies. Oh my gosh. I was a hot mess. I have a photo of myself holding Isabelle right after she was born. I look like I fell out of a moving vehicle or something. I look so wrecked.
这在你看来真实吗？我拍这一集时还没有孩子。我只想说我生完孩子后看起来不那样。哦，天哪。我当时一团糟。我有一张自己刚生完伊莎贝尔后抱着她的照片。我看起来就像从一辆行驶的车辆里摔出来一样。我看起来太崩溃了。
And I'm smiling and you can tell I'm so happy, but my smile looks so weary. You know, I'm just like, well, I remember them like, oh, let's pull some of your hair out because, you know, we had this whole conversation. Let's give you a half up, half down do. It was very centered on the hair. What is Pam's hair after she's given birth? And like, okay, there's been a moment she settled in her room. So maybe she took a second to brush it.
我在笑，你能看出我很高兴，但我的笑容看起来那么疲惫。你知道的，我只是觉得，好吧，我记得他们说，哦，让我们把你的头发扯下来一点，因为，你知道，我们有这个全体讨论。让我们给你弄个半扎发。这非常以头发为中心。帕姆生完孩子后的头发是什么样的？而且，好吧，有一个时刻她安顿在病房里。所以也许她花了一秒钟梳理了一下。
There was like all of this conversation about my hair. Who's brushing their hair right after they give birth? Nobody. Well, here's the thing. I have all these photos from right after my son was born. He was my first and my hair is so insane looking. And I remember talking to my friend Christina Applegate about these pictures and she was like, oh, honey, oh, honey, did no one tell you to bring a headband?
有关于我头发的各种讨论。谁会在刚生完孩子后梳头？没有人。好吧，事情是这样的。我有很多我儿子刚出生时的照片。他我的第一个孩子，我的头发看起来太疯狂了。我记得和我的朋友克里斯蒂安·阿普尔盖特聊起这些照片时，她说，哦，亲爱的，哦，亲爱的，难道没有人告诉你带一个发带吗？
You bring a headband so that then all the little pictures that you take after you've given birth, like you're not afraid to show people. You put the little headband on and that takes care of it. And I was like, okay, got it. Headband. So when my daughter was born, I was like, babe, don't forget the headband. We got to bring the headband. So that was then in the pictures with my daughter.
你带一个发带，这样你在生完孩子后拍的所有小照片里，你就不怕给别人看了。你戴上那个小发带，那就搞定了。当时我就想，好吧，明白了。发带。所以当我的女儿出生时，我就想，宝贝，别忘了发带。我们得带上发带。所以后来和我女儿的合照里就有了这个。
And it looks even more insane. I look even crazier. Oh my God. Also, I've never worn a headband. I'm not a headband gal. So I was like, then I was like, Christina, were you pranking me? Like what? Wear a fedora.
而且它看起来更疯狂了。我看起来更抓狂了。哦，天哪。另外，我从来没戴过发带。我不是戴发带的人。所以我当时想，然后我对克里斯蒂安说，你是在整我吗？什么鬼？戴一顶呢帽。
No one will ask anything. Exactly. Wear a hat. It was so crazy. But when I look back on this episode and I see this scene that is supposedly right after she's birthed this baby, the one thing I think of is just like, well, that is not what my hair looked like. No.
没人会问任何问题。没错。戴顶帽子。这太疯狂了。但当我回看这一集并看到这个据说是她生完孩子后不久的场景时，我脑子里唯一想到的就是，好吧，我的头发可不是长那样。不。
And we should celebrate what our hair looks like. The messy craziness that it is. That's right. Jim is going to enter the waiting room. He's so proud. He's going to announce the birth of Cecilia Marie Halpert. Before he can say she's seven pounds, Michael says she's 11 pounds. Michael's doing the thing where he takes over a conference room meeting.
我们应该赞美我们的头发本来的样子。那种凌乱的疯狂状态。没错。吉姆要走进候诊室了。他太骄傲了。他要宣布塞西莉亚·玛丽·哈尔珀特的诞生。在他还没来得及说她七磅重之前，迈克尔说她有十一磅。迈克尔又在搞那种接管会议室会议的事情了。
But Jim says mother and daughter are doing great and everyone is so happy. So happy. And they go to run to hug Jim and Michael steps in the middle and they all hug Michael. I wrote that down. It's at three minutes and 15 seconds. I went to the script to see if it said that like Kelly and Meredith hugged Michael first. It doesn't. That was obviously just like a funny bit we found in the moment.
但吉姆说母女平安，大家都非常高兴。非常高兴。他们跑过去拥抱吉姆，迈克尔插在中间，结果他们全都抱了迈克尔。我把这个记下来了。在三分十五秒的时候。我去查了剧本，看上面是不是写着凯莉和梅雷迪思先拥抱了迈克尔。上面没有。那显然只是我们在现场发现的一个有趣的包袱。
There's so many fun little catches in this scene. Also, did you notice how Phyllis eats a cake? Yes. Why is her face covered with icing? I don't know. She brought the cake real close to her face. Yeah. And did you notice who did not attend the birth?
这一场戏里有太多有趣的隐藏笑点了。还有，你注意到菲莉丝是怎么吃蛋糕的吗？是的。为什么她脸上沾满了糖霜？我不知道。她把蛋糕离脸太近了。是的。还有，你注意到谁没有出席分娩吗？
Besides Toby, Angela, Stanley, Creed, and of course Dwight are not there. Oh, wow. Yes. Yeah. Well, Pam's mom, of course, is there. She walks in with coffee for Jim and Pam. Pam is so happy to have coffee because she said she hasn't had caffeine in nine months. And I would like to point out some real gym sass at three minutes, 30 seconds.
除了托比，安吉拉、斯坦利、克里德，当然还有德怀特都不在。哦，哇。是的。是的。好吧，帕姆的妈妈当然在了。她带着给吉姆和帕姆的咖啡走进来。帕姆很高兴能喝到咖啡，因为她说她已经九个月没碰咖啡因了。我想指出在三分三十秒时吉姆的一些真实傲娇。
He looks at camera like, yeah, okay. I have to say if you go back and look at episodes when Pam is pregnant, you can see her drinking coffee. Really? Yes. I've been noticing. I have another background catch from this scene. Did you see the book on Pam's bedside table?
他冲着镜头露出了“好吧，行吧”的表情。我不得不说，如果你回去看帕姆怀孕时的剧集，你可以看到她在喝咖啡。真的吗？是的。我注意到了。我从这个场景中找到了另一个背景彩蛋。你看到帕姆床头柜上的那本书了吗？
No. It is Joe Bennett's book. Take a good look. Oh. She brought it to the hospital. Okay. That's such a great catch. Well, now CC is going to need a diaper change.
没有。那是乔·贝内特的书。仔细看。哦。她把它带到医院了。好吧。这真是一个绝妙的彩蛋。好吧，现在茜茜需要换尿布了。
Jim volunteers and he's going to have a talking head where he explains that he's a diapering master. He has been practicing. He's been practicing on everything. Yeah. Footballs. And a cat. Yes, and a cat.
吉姆自告奋勇，他会有一个采访镜头，解释说他是换尿布大师。他一直在练习。他一直在练习所有东西。是的。橄榄球。还有猫。是的，还有猫。
Angela, we got a lot of fan mail asking, how did we diaper a cat? You were there. Well, I was there, but I did no diapering of the cat. Randy shared with us that we used the always reliable Bob Dunn's animal rentals and Denise Sanders came through again. Denise was so great. She was always there when we were working with cats. It required two prep days and a few rehearsals.
安吉拉，我们收到了很多粉丝来信问，我们是怎么给猫换尿布的？你当时在场。好吧，我在场，但我可没给猫换尿布。兰迪跟我们分享说，我们用了永远可靠的鲍勃·邓恩动物租赁公司，丹妮丝·桑德斯再次出力了。丹妮丝太棒了。我们跟猫合作时她总是在场。这需要两天的筹备和几次排练。
What was it like for Denise to get an email from Randy? Oh, my gosh. I imagine their email exchanges. Hi, Denise. We're going to need to diaper a cat. Hi, Denise. Is it okay if Angela licks the face of a cat? I mean, hi, Denise.
丹妮丝收到兰迪的邮件时是什么样的？哦，天哪。我能想象他们的邮件往来。嗨，丹妮丝。我们需要给一只猫换尿布。嗨，丹妮丝。安吉拉舔猫的脸可以吗？我是说，嗨，丹妮丝。
We're going to throw a cat into a ceiling. Email me back. Randy said we tried to get milkman. You remember milkman was bandit. Yep. But milkman was already booked. He worked a lot. Busy working actor.
我们要把一只猫扔进天花板。给我回邮件。兰迪说我们试图找米尔克曼。你们还记得米尔克曼就是班迪特吗？是的。但米尔克曼已经被预订了。他工作很多。是个忙碌的演员。
I guess Randy said milkman was in hot demand because he was very disciplined and a reliable working kitty. I want to see milkman's resume. So we used a different cat as close to milkman's coloring as possible to attempt to make the cheat. Well, I'll say this. I noticed that we don't see Jim actually diapering. Of course not.
我猜兰迪说米尔克曼非常抢手，因为他很有纪律性，是一只可靠的打工人小猫。我想看米尔克曼的简历。所以我们用了另一只毛色尽可能接近米尔克曼的猫来试图作弊完成拍摄。好吧，我得说这个。我注意到我们没有看到吉姆真正地换尿布。当然没有。
The cat is pre-diapered and we just pan up to Jim taking credit. Yeah. Well, Michael is finally going to get to hold the baby. He comes in the room, congratulates Helene on being a grandma. So awkward. Oh, that whole exchange was so cringy. And Michael does this thing, but I couldn't help but just see Steve in this moment when he was like, I want to hold the baby.
这只猫是提前穿好尿布的，我们只是把镜头摇到吉姆身上让他邀功。是的。好吧，迈克尔终于抱到孩子了。他走进房间，祝贺海伦当了奶奶。太尴尬了。哦，整段交流都太尴尬了。迈克尔做了个动作，但我忍不住在这个时刻看到了史蒂夫的影子，当时他说，我想抱抱猫……抱抱孩子。
I thought the same things. Steve Carell loves a baby. Yes. He's such a good dad and a family man. And I was like, I bet Steve in real life was so delighted to hold that baby. I love how Michael sanitizes his hands and then wipes his hands on his pants and Pam is like, again, no pants. Yeah.
我有同感。史蒂夫·卡瑞尔超级喜欢小婴儿。是的。他是个那么好的爸爸和顾家好男人。我当时就想，我敢打赌史蒂夫在现实生活中一定很高兴能抱抱那个孩子。我喜欢迈克尔先给手消毒，然后把手在裤子上擦干净，而帕姆说，又是这样，没穿裤子。是的。
We got a fan question from KJ Davy in Charlotte, North Carolina. Where did you get such a teeny, tiny newborn baby to play the part of CC? KJ, I'm going to give you a baby breakdown. There were two sets of twins that played baby CC. But if you can believe it, we actually held auditions for these babies. For the babies? Mm-hmm. The babies had to come, slate their name.
我们收到了来自北卡罗来纳州夏洛特的 KJ 戴维的粉丝提问。你们从哪找来这么一个小不点的新生儿来演茜茜的？KJ，我来给你做个婴儿解析。扮演婴儿茜茜的有两对双胞胎。但如果你敢相信的话，我们其实为这些婴儿举行了试镜。为婴儿们？嗯嗯。婴儿们必须来，报上名字。
Tell us to profile photos. Exactly. Randy arranged to have five sets of twins come to set one day. And John and I went and we held all the babies. They wanted to see which ones responded to us. I guess it was like a chemistry check. Aw. And in the end, we had Elijah and Spencer Wolfe and Ella and Finnegan Sanders play baby CC.
给我们看证件照。没错。兰迪安排了五对双胞胎有一天来到片场。我和约翰去了，我们抱了所有的婴儿。他们想看看哪些婴儿对我们有反应。我猜这就像是一场化学反应测试。啊。最后，我们让伊利亚和斯派克·沃尔夫以及埃拉和芬尼根·桑德斯来扮演婴儿茜茜。
There are some rules about babies working. Thank goodness. You have to be 15 days old before you can work on a TV show or movie in California. All of our babies were around six weeks old, but they had been premies. So that is why they were still so tiny at that age. Babies can only be on set for two hours total. So from the moment they park their car until they get back in their car can be two hours. And they're only allowed to work for 20 minutes of that two hours.
关于婴儿工作有一些规定。谢天谢地。在加州，你必须出生满 15 天才能在电视节目或电影中工作。我们所有的婴儿大约六周大，但他们曾经是早产儿。这就是为什么他们在那个年纪依然那么小。婴儿在片场总共只能待两个小时。所以从他们把车停好到重新上车必须是两个小时。并且他们在这两个小时里只被允许工作 20 分钟。
Right. And they have their own trailer dressing room area where they can be with their parents when they're not working. And they are assigned a nurse. Yes. That accompanies them to the set. Correct. And this is why we needed two sets of twins because that way we had 80 minutes of on-camera
没错。他们有自己的拖车化妆间区域，不工作时可以和父母待在那里。并且给他们指派了一名护士。是的。陪同他们去片场。没错。这就是为什么我们需要两对双胞胎，因为这样我们总共有 80 分钟的镜头前
baby time total. We also used a fakie baby, which we called jelly baby and creepy baby. They are really creepy. They are made from kind of a soft, pliable cast polymer. You shared on the commentary that they were actually heavier than the real babies. Yes. And their heads were super floppy. So you actually had to like hold their heads.
婴儿出镜时间。我们还用了一个假婴儿，我们叫它果冻婴儿和诡异婴儿。它们真的很诡异。它们是由一种柔软、易弯曲的铸造聚合物制成的。你在随片评论中分享说，它们实际上比真正的婴儿还要重。是的。而且它们的头超级软。所以你实际上必须托住它们的头。
Just like a real baby. Yeah. They were much heavier and it was jelly. They were gelatinous. Yeah. I mean, it was weird. It's the same people, I think, that made fakie banded. Yeah.
就像真正的婴儿一样。是的。它们重得多，而且是果冻状的。它们是明胶状的。是的。我是说，这很诡异。我想，制作假班迪特的也是同一群人。是的。
And he was a jelly cat. Mm-hmm. You also shared on the commentary that at eight minutes, 52 seconds, when the nurse rolls CC out of the room, you know, she's in her crib and she's going to roll her out. That's the fake baby. If you go back and watch, it's not even moving at all. Yes. I believe we also used fakie baby in a good portion of the scene with Clark.
而且他是一只果冻猫。嗯嗯。你在随片评论中还分享说，在 8 分钟 52 秒时，当护士把茜茜推出房间时，你知道的，她在她的婴儿床里，她要把她推出去。那是假婴儿。如果你回去看，它甚至根本没有动。是的。我相信我们在与克拉克的对手戏的大部分里也使用了假婴儿。
Mm-hmm. You might notice you don't really ever see a baby there. Right. Yeah. Should we talk about what Dwight is doing now? Oh my gosh. He couldn't find the iPod, but guess what he found? Mold.
嗯嗯。你可能会注意到你在那儿真的从没看到过一个活生生的婴儿。对。是的。我们该聊聊德怀特现在在做什么了吗？哦，天哪。他找不到 iPod 了，但你猜他找到了什么？霉菌。
And a lot of it. Yeah. He wants to solve this mold problem for them, but first he needs to do, I mean, obviously, what anyone would do. Right. If you show up to tackle mold, you read a book, you take a bath in someone's bathtub, you sleep in their bed. Without any, um, bottoms.
而且有很多。是的。他想为他们解决这个霉菌问题，但首先他需要做的是，显然，任何人都会做的事。没错。如果你赶去处理霉菌，你就读读书，在别人的浴缸里洗个澡，在他们的床上睡觉。不穿任何，呃，
Bottoms. Mm-hmm. Yeah. Commando. Question for you. Mm-hmm. Did the documentary crew stay overnight at Jim and Pam's? I don't know.
下半身衣物。下半身。嗯嗯。对。真空上阵。有个问题问你。嗯嗯。纪录片摄制组在吉姆和帕姆家过夜了吗？我不知道。
How many cameramen do they have on this day? What's their budget for this documentary? They've got cameras back at the office. They've got some over in the hospital. They're following Dwight as well. Yeah. They are committed. I wanted to point out that at five minutes one second, that exterior shot of Dwight breaking
他们这一天有多少摄像师？他们这部纪录片的预算是多少？他们在办公室里有摄像机。他们在医院里也有一些。他们也在追踪德怀特。是的。他们太敬业了。我想指出，在 5 分钟 1 秒时，德怀特破门而入的那个外景镜头
into Jim and Pam's house, I mean, he literally elbows the window and it breaks. Right. Because he doesn't want to know where the keys are. La-la-la-la-la. Don't know. No. Don't tell me. He's going to get in.
来到吉姆和帕姆的房子，我是说，他真的用手肘撞了窗户，窗户就碎了。没错。因为他不想知道钥匙放在哪儿。啦啦啦啦啦。不知道。不。别告诉我。他要进去了。
Mm-hmm. First of all, that was breakaway glass. But second of all, that was also built on our stages. That exterior, they literally rebuilt the exterior of that real house to do just that little break-in bit. It is lit so well. I mean, our set builders had a very busy week. Yeah.
嗯哼。首先，那是易碎玻璃。但其次，这也是在我们的摄影棚搭建的。那个外景，他们真的重建了那个真实房子的外景，就为了拍那个小小的破门而入的桥段。灯光打得太好了。我是说，我们的布景师度过了非常忙碌的一周。是啊。
There's going to be another thing that I'm going to talk about later where we fake outside and we actually shot it on the warehouse set. And I just have to give a shout out to our lighting crew because they really made these places look like we were outside, but really we were in a warehouse. Well, listen, Dwight is well rested. He's ready to get to work. He's going to demo their kitchen to get rid of the mold. Yeah.
接下来我还要讲另一件事，我们在那里伪造了外景，而我们实际上是在仓库布景里拍摄的。我必须对我们的灯光组大声赞美，因为他们真的把这些地方弄得好像我们在室外一样，但实际上我们在仓库里。好吧，听着，德怀特休息得很好。他准备好开始工作了。他要拆了他们的厨房来除霉。是啊。
So on the commentary, they shared that that side of the cabinet where he swings the sledgehammer. Yeah. They had scored it a little so that when he hit it, it would like break apart. Okay. It wouldn't break apart. What? He swung that thing and hit it several times and nothing happened. So it was actually really hard to get a shot of them really whacking into that thing.
所以在评论音轨中，他们分享说他挥舞大锤的那个橱柜侧面。是啊。他们稍微划痕了一下，这样当他击打它时，它就会像裂开一样。好吧。它不会裂开。什么？他挥舞那东西打了几下，什么也没发生。所以要拍到他们真正猛烈敲打那个东西的镜头其实真的很难。
That's so funny to me. I mean, he could crush an apple with his bare hands, but they couldn't get that cabinet to break. Well, I must have been a really sturdy cabinet. Should we go back to Dunder Mithlin and see what everyone else is doing? Oh, we definitely should. Michael is doing that thing where he is taking responsibility for something he had nothing to do with.
这对我来说太搞笑了。我是说，他可以用双手捏碎一个苹果，但他们却弄不碎那个橱柜。好吧，那一定是个非常结实的橱柜。我们要不要回到邓德米夫林，看看其他人都在做什么？哦，我们绝对应该。迈克尔正在做那种事，他把一件跟他毫无关系的事揽上身。
Oh, Jim and Pam. He's the matchmaker. He is. And he's going to start matching up everyone in the office. That's right. This scene had a series of talking heads. First was Meredith. You know, she said she's single, obviously.
哦，吉姆和帕姆。他是媒人。他是。他要在办公室里开始撮合每一个人。没错。这一场戏有一系列的大头访问。首先是梅雷迪思。你知道，她说她是单身，很明显。
She's never getting married and her talking head is like Clooney. Mm-hmm. Meredith is our office's George Clooney. Yeah. Who knew? Andy has one, of course, where he talks about Aaron. He's hoping the stars will align for them. And then Jenna would have come Creed's.
她永远不会结婚，而她的大头访问就像克鲁尼。嗯哼。梅雷迪思是我们办公室的乔治·克鲁尼。是啊。谁知道呢？安迪当然也有一个，他在里面谈到艾伦。他希望他们能喜结良缘。然后珍娜，接下来应该是克里德的。
Remember this deleted runner I shared with you that he thought if Jim and Pam had their baby, that meant he was going to die? Yes. Okay. Well, now Pam has had the baby and he's still alive. Here's Creed's deleted talking head. Pam and her baby. And I'm still alive.
还记得我跟你分享过的那个被删掉的支线剧情吗，他以为如果吉姆和帕姆有了孩子，那就意味着他要死了？是的。好吧，现在帕姆已经有了孩子，他还活着。这是克里德被删掉的大头访问。帕姆和她的孩子。而我还活着。
I have a new lease on life. If death can't stop me from dating, then neither can my mother. What? Who is his mother? And she's still alive and she doesn't want him to date. I have so many questions. Well, listen, bottom line, Michael is going to fill all of their empty holes with love. With another body and love.
我的人生焕发了新生。如果连死都不能阻止我约会，那我妈也别想。什么？谁是他妈？她还活着，而且不希望他约会。我有太多问题了。好吧，听着，归根结底，迈克尔要用爱填满他们所有空虚的洞。用另一个躯体和爱。
Yes. And Angela, your look when he says that is so funny. It's so good. So Jim and Pam are reminiscing about when they were just a couple of kids afraid to be parents and here they are holding their baby. Oh, it's so peaceful. And they're just laying there together in a sweet little snuggle staring into her cute little sleeping face.
是的。安吉拉，当他说那句话时，你的表情太搞笑了。太棒了。所以吉姆和帕姆在回忆他们当初只是两个害怕当父母的年轻人，而现在他们抱着自己的孩子。哦，太宁静了。他们就这样依偎在一起躺在那里，凝视着她可爱的小睡脸。
Yeah. And the nurse is like, would you like us to take her? Yeah. And Jim and Pam say no. No, no, no. She can just stay here with us. Yeah. And this of course cuts to Cecilia crying.
是的。护士说，你们想让我们把她抱走吗？是的。吉姆和帕姆说不。不，不，不。她可以跟我们待在这儿。是的。这当然切换到了塞西莉亚在哭。
They're struggling to breastfeed, to swaddle. The wheels are coming off the bus. I have a very funny story about that swaddling moment. So we were supposed to not swaddle the baby. That's the joke is that Jim and Pam. Don't know how. Yes. They need the nurse.
他们正在努力进行母乳喂养，努力给婴儿打包裹。情况彻底失控了。关于那个打包裹的时刻，我有一个非常搞笑的故事。所以我们本来应该不给婴儿打包裹的。笑点就在于吉姆和帕姆。不知道怎么做。是的。他们需要护士。
We're overwhelmed. Right. Lady, every time we just swaddled that baby perfectly. The two of you? The two of us. It was insane. We were trying to be bad at swaddling. Neither one of us had kids.
我们不知所措。对的。天哪，每次我们都把那个婴儿包裹得完美无缺。你们两个？我们两个。太疯狂了。我们当时在努力假装不会打包裹。我们俩都没有孩子。
And somehow we were like masterful swaddlers. And Harold Ramis and our AD, they kept saying, guys, stop swaddling the baby. The joke is you can't do it. But we just, I don't know. We were really, really good at swaddling. They were like, you have to stop. You have to stop swaddling that baby.
而不知怎么的，我们就像是打包裹大师。哈罗德·雷米斯和我们的副导演，他们一直说，伙计们，别给婴儿打包裹了。笑点是你们不会做。但我们就是，我不知道。我们真的非常非常擅长打包裹。他们一直在说，你们得停下。你们得停止给那个婴儿打包裹。
Well, there was a deleted scene after this. I think they were trying to build out the story that the two of you were getting really frustrated and started to get a little short with one another. Oh, I remember. Oh, I felt like we had to hear it. Pam cusses out Jim. And I think she flipped some of the bird at the end.
好吧，这之后有一个被删减的场面。我想他们是想构建这样一个故事：你们两个变得非常沮丧，开始对彼此有点不耐烦了。哦，我记得。哦，我觉得我们必须听听这个。帕姆对吉姆爆粗口。我想她最后还竖了中指。
Oh yeah. She shoots some of the bird. I remember. Delivery wasn't so bad, right? Yeah. F*** you. Wow. Well, no, I just mean a wonderful ending.
哦，是的。她竖了一下中指。我记得。发挥得还不错吧？是啊。操你的。哇。好吧，不，我的意思是这是一个美妙的结局。
Kind of rough getting here. We did not handle that well. I think you have to admit you flipped out a little bit. I think you should stop talking now. Okay. Uh-oh. Someone's still a little sore. You sitting on your donut?
走到这一步有点艰难。我们处理得不太好。我想你必须承认你有点失控了。我想你现在该闭嘴了。好吧。噢哦。有人还是觉得有点隐隐作痛。你坐在你的甜甜圈坐垫上了吗？
Okay. So I remember shooting that and we had a lot of fun with that. It looks like it. We had a lot of conversations with the people on set who had kids and they all verified this is a very authentic moment. Post birth. It did not end up making it in, but it was pretty fun. It didn't.
好吧。所以我记得拍摄那个场景时，我们拍得很开心。看起来确实如此。我们和剧组里有孩子的那些人进行了很多交流，他们都证实这是一个非常真实的时刻。产后。它最终没能被剪进正片里，但确实挺有趣的。没有。
And I remember the show notes that said that it just made Jim seem too mean. Yes. Even though these moments do happen between couples. They do, but I feel like they left enough in of them being frustrated about like breastfeeding and I think it works. It works. We got a fan question from Hildi N in Norway who was curious about the breastfeeding shawl or whatever it is you call it that Pam is using in the
我记得剧本笔记上说，那只是让吉姆显得太刻薄了。是的。尽管这些时刻确实会在伴侣之间发生。确实会，但我感觉他们保留了足够多的他们对母乳喂养感到沮丧的镜头，而且我觉得效果不错。效果很好。我们收到了来自挪威的希尔迪·N的一个粉丝提问，她对帕姆在这个场景中使用的哺乳披肩或其他什么叫作的东西很好奇。
scene. Is it a display of nudity on the show or is this normal in a US hospital? Do women in US hospitals use these shawls when they are breastfeeding? I would say no. Not in their room, not in the privacy of their room, but maybe if you were out in the hallway or something, you might have a little blanket or something. I had one of these shawls.
这是剧中的裸露镜头，还是这是美国医院的常态？美国医院的女性在哺乳时会使用这些披肩吗？我想说不会。不在她们的房间里，不在她们房间的私密空间里，但也许如果你去走廊或什么地方，你可能会带一条小毯子之类的东西。我有一个这样的披肩。
They're actually really great. When I got to use it on the show and when I had my kids in real life, I was like, I want that one that Pam used because it has this like wire that holds it open so the mom can peek in. It was actually really helpful. And I would use one of those for the times that if I had to breastfeed at a restaurant or at the airport or wherever, maybe if I was in a very public place, although I would like to say there's nothing wrong with just whipping
它们其实真的很棒。当我在剧中用到它，以及当我在现实生活中有了孩子时，我想的是，我想要帕姆用的那种，因为它有一根像铁丝一样的东西把它撑开，这样妈妈可以偷看里面。这其实非常有用。在某些情况下我会用这种披肩，如果我不得不在餐馆、机场或任何地方哺乳，也许如果我在一个非常公共的场所，尽管我想说，女士们，直接掏出来喂并没有什么不对。
it out, ladies. Your baby's got to eat. Your baby's got to eat. I was such a fan of this one shopping mall after Isabel was little that I would go. It was like an outdoor mall and I would have her in her stroller and we could walk around. And for me, it was just being able to get out of the house and get outside a
你的宝宝得吃东西。你的宝宝得吃东西。伊莎贝尔还小的时候，我特别喜欢某个购物中心，我会去那里。那是一个露天商场，我会把她放在婴儿车里，我们可以到处走走。对当时的劳资我来说，能够离开家去户外待一会儿，就已经是。
little bit. But I loved it because they had nursing stations. I know what you're talking about. They had a little room with a rocking chair in it. Yes. And you could go in. So whenever I see a nursing station anywhere, I always smile because I'm like, that is so thoughtful.
但我很喜欢它，因为那里有哺乳室。我知道你在说什么。他们有一个带摇椅的小房间。是的。你可以走进去。所以无论我在哪里看到哺乳室，我总是会微笑，因为我想，这太贴心了。
Now they have them in airports. They did not have them in airports when I had my kids. Yeah. Not when we had kids. But I guess in answer to Hildi's question, we were using that on the show just for the purposes of we couldn't have nudity on television. And also that was a fakey baby under there. We needed to limit what you saw of the babies in addition to the boobies.
现在他们在机场里也有了。我生孩子的时候机场里可没有。是的。我们生孩子的时候没有。但我想为了回答希尔迪的问题，我们在剧中使用那个只是为了不能在电视上有裸露镜头的需要。而且那下面是一个假娃娃。除了奶子，我们需要限制你看到的婴儿的部分。
And also it was fakey nipple. You were wearing that rigged bra with the special pacifier thingy. Oh my God. I forgot about that, Angela. Yes. Jenna, on the DVD commentary, you talked about this elaborate breastfeeding bra rig that they had to build and you wore so it would look like Pam was actually breastfeeding.
而且那也是假乳头。你当时穿着那个带特殊安抚奶嘴玩意的特制胸罩。噢天哪。我把那事给忘了，安吉拉。是的。珍娜，你在DVD评论音轨中谈到过这个精心制作的哺乳胸罩装置，剧组不得不制作它，而你穿着它，这样看起来就像帕姆真的在哺乳一样。
I remember that now. The baby had to want to have their face by my boob. But obviously not near your boob. So what do you do? You describe it in the commentary. I thought we should hear it. Now there was like a rig, right, with the pacifier. Oh, so complicated.
我现在想起来了。婴儿得愿意把脸贴在我的奶子上。但显然又不能贴近你的奶子。那你怎么办？你在评论音轨里描述过。我觉得我们应该听听。当时有个装置，对吧，带有安抚奶嘴。哦，太复杂了。
Yes, because you wanted the baby to cry, but then it had to stop crying so you could record our dialogue. So they built me a bra that had extra padding so it looked like I was breastfeeding or my breasts were full of milk. But then it also had like a breakaway shield that revealed a sterile nipple pacifier thing. And then the baby would actually suck on this pacifier and stop crying. How about that?
是的，因为你希望婴儿哭，但接着它必须停止哭泣，这样你才能录制我们的对话。所以他们给我做了一个胸罩，里面有额外的衬垫，看起来就像我在哺乳，或者我的乳房涨满了奶汁。但它还有一个可分离的遮挡板，露出了一个无菌的乳头安抚奶嘴装置。然后婴儿就会真的吮吸这个安抚奶嘴并停止哭泣。怎么样？
You go to work one day, you get an email. Can you build a bra with a pacifier in it that you wore over your clothes? Here's the thing. They could change out the pacifier. They were constantly changing it out with a new sterile pacifier as well so that we'd get nipple change. Nipple change? Who knew?
你有一天去上班，收到一封电子邮件。你能做一个里面带安抚奶嘴的胸罩，穿在衣服外面吗？事情是这样的。他们可以换掉安抚奶嘴。他们一直在换上新的无菌安抚奶嘴，这样我们就能实现乳头更换。乳头更换？谁知道呢？
Well, in all of this struggle, Jim is going to buzz the nurse. Oh, but I mean, did he buzz the nurse? Maybe Pam sat on it. But here she is to help us. Well, the nurse is going to offer to take baby CC to the nursery and they can try again later. Yeah. And she said, you know what, if she gets hungry, we'll give her a bottle.
好吧，在所有这些挣扎中，吉姆按了护士铃。哦，我是说，他真的按了护士铃吗？也许是帕姆坐在上面了。但她来帮我们了。嗯，护士主动提出把小西西带到婴儿室，他们可以晚点再试一次。是的。她说，你知道吗，如果她饿了，我们会给她一个奶瓶。
And Pam's like, no, no, no, I've heard about this. This is like nipple confusion. Then she'll just want the bottle and then she won't want to breastfeed. And when Pam says this to the nurse, she gets some real nurse sass. The nurse is like, oh good, you know everything. Lady, the line, oh good, you know everything is our fan mail flurry. Really? Yes.
帕姆说，不，不，不，我听说过这个。这就像乳头混淆。然后她就会只想要奶瓶，接着她就不想进行母乳喂养了。当帕姆对护士说这话时，她得到了真正的护士式傲慢回应。护士说，哦太好了，什么都知道。女士，哦太好了，什么都知道这句台词引发了我们的粉丝来信狂潮。真的吗？是的。
That's what said everyone off phrase. Really, really bumped people. For example, Alyssa M. from Utah said, I'm a postpartum nurse and I love this episode, but I always cringe at how the nurse treats Jim and Pam. Corey from Rochester, New York said, nipple confusion is real. You are the expert because you're the mother. Intuition is real. And finally from Katie G. and Greenville, South Carolina.
那是让所有人大跌眼镜的时刻。真的，真的让人感到很不舒服。例如，来自犹他州的阿莉莎·M说，我是一名产后护士，我很喜欢这一集，但我总是对护士对待吉姆和帕姆的方式感到尴尬。来自纽约州罗切斯特的科里说，乳头混淆是真实存在的。你才是专家，因为你是母亲。直觉是真实存在的。最后来自南卡罗来纳州格林维尔的凯蒂·G。
All right, ladies, I have a small soapbox to get on here. First, I want to really applaud everyone on the show for depicting some much more realistic pregnancy birth breastfeeding scenes. I love that Pam is scared and showing how long labor can be and especially how difficult it can be to get the hang of breastfeeding. But as for the soapbox, that nurse. Uh-oh. Every time I watch this episode, I end up fuming at that nurse for giving Pam sass about, oh good, you know everything. News alert, nipple confusion is real. And the mother gets to make the choice as to whether she wants her child to have a bottle, pacifier, anything.
好了，女士们，我要在这里发表一番长篇大论了。首先，我要大大赞扬剧中的每个人，因为他们刻画了一些更加真实的怀孕、分娩、母乳喂养的场景。我很喜欢帕姆感到害怕，并展现了产程可以有多漫长，尤其是掌握母乳喂养可以有多困难。但至于长篇大论的主题，那个护士。噢哦。每次我看这一集，我最终都会因为那个护士对帕姆说哦太好了，什么都知道而气得发狂。突发新闻，乳头混淆是真实存在的。母亲有权选择她是否希望自己的孩子使用奶瓶、安抚奶嘴或任何东西。
And that nurse, whom in a deleted scene we learned has never had children herself, has no right to give Pam attitude about her decision. Katie, go off. The mama bear and me really wants to storm into that room, push that nurse out and assure Pam that she's doing a wonderful job. Gah, that nurse. She goes on to say, ladies, stand up for yourselves. Don't be bullied and know that you're doing an amazing job regardless. Hang in there, mamas. Thank you for letting me get that off my chest.
而那个护士——我们在一个被删减的场景中得知她自己从未有过孩子——根本没有权力对帕姆的决定态度恶劣。凯蒂，爆发吧。我体内的母狮子真的很想冲进那个房间，把那个护士推出去，向帕姆保证她做得非常棒。气死我了，那个护士。她接着说，女士们，站起来为自己维权。不要被霸凌，要知道无论如何你们都做得非常棒。坚持住，妈妈们。谢谢你们让我一吐为快。
Since my second child is due in mid-October, I'm absolutely keyed up about this issue right now. Katie, we hear you. Katie, I love you. Yeah. Oh, there is actually one more from Kim E. in Ohio. Not so much a question as a thank you. I struggled and gave up trying to breastfeed my son and then didn't even attempt with my daughter two years later. I don't know if the office was the first to do it, but it was the first time I saw a new mother on a television show having trouble breastfeeding.
既然我的第二个孩子预产期在十月中旬，我现在对这个问题绝对高度紧张。凯蒂，我们听到你的心声了。凯蒂，我爱你。是的。哦，来自俄亥俄州的金·E还有最后一条。与其说是提问，不如说是感谢。我曾挣扎着并最终放弃了母乳喂养我的儿子，然后在两年后生女儿时甚至都没有尝试。我不知道《办公室》是不是第一部这样做的，但这是我第一次看到电视剧中的新手妈妈在母乳喂养方面遇到困难。
It made me emotional when watching this, even though it was five years since my son was born that this episode originally aired. Thank your writers for realizing that it isn't always so easy. Thank you, Jenna, for taking your character there. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Well, I am really touched by all of those letters. Thank you.
看这个的时候我很受触动，尽管距离我儿子出生、这一集最初播出已经过去五年了。感谢你们的编剧，他们意识到这并不总是那么容易。谢谢你，珍娜，把你的角色带到了那种境地。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。好吧，我真的很为所有这些信件所感动。谢谢。
I know. Thank you, ladies, for sharing. I didn't even know how accurate Pam's journey was when I shot it. But in this rewatch, I was just as grateful for our depiction of this struggle. Right. I mean, I remember with Isabelle saying to her, it was just me and her in the room. It was just quiet. I was trying to get her to latch.
我懂。谢谢你们，女士们，谢谢你们的分享。我拍摄时甚至不知道帕姆的这段经历有多准确。但在这次重温中，我同样感激我们对这种挣扎的描绘。对。我是说，我记得对伊莎贝尔说过，房间里只有我和她。四周很安静。我正试图让她含住乳头。
And I remember I was so tired and I just looked at her sweet little face and I said, baby girl, I don't know how to do this. And I know you don't know how to do it, but we're going to figure it out. I promise you. And then I like started to cry. It's like happy tears, like, but also frustrated tears. I didn't get the hang of breastfeeding either of my children until after I got home from the hospital. I did not leave the hospital like Pam. I did not leave the hospital.
我记得我当时太累了，我只是看着她可爱的小脸说，宝贝女儿，我不知道该怎么做。我知道你也不知道怎么做，但我们会弄明白的。我向你保证。然后我差不多哭了起来。这就像是幸福的泪水，但也是沮丧的泪水。我直到从医院回家后，才真正掌握了我两个孩子的母乳喂养技巧。我没有像帕姆那样离开医院。我没有离开医院。
Lady, I got only with this flowing. I only got one boob figured out, you know, my left boob got it. My right boob never got it. Eventually we got there with the right boob. I wanted to point out something else in this scene at eight minutes and 54 seconds. I don't know if you noticed, but I am still wearing a fake belly. I think you can really see it when I'm sitting in the bed in these scenes. Yeah, I did notice that.
天哪，我只有这个在流淌。我只搞懂了一个奶子，你知道的，我的左奶搞懂了。我的右奶从来没搞懂过。最终我们的右奶也成功了。我想指出这一幕中在八分五十四秒处的另一件事。我不知道你们有没有注意到，我仍然戴着假肚子。我想当我在这些场景中坐在床上时，你真的能看到它。是的，我注意到了。
I thought that was a great touch. Lady, that was really important to me. I pitched that. Now, I know I've shared that I hadn't had a baby, but you had had a baby. And I remember being in the hospital with you after you gave birth. And I was like, well, wait, her whole stomach didn't go down. No. And no one told me that.
我觉得这是一个很棒的点缀。天哪，这对我来说真的很重要。这是我提出来的。现在，我知道我曾分享过我当时没有生过孩子，但你生过孩子。我记得你生完孩子后我在医院陪着你。我说，等等，她的整个肚子没有瘪下去。没有。而且没有人告诉我这件事。
And I have three older sisters and I guess I was just so naive. I packed my little hospital bag, you know, and the outfit I picked to go home in were my skinny jeans and just a cute little top. I remember. And I could not get those jeans on or button the top. I don't know what I was thinking. I literally had no clothes to leave the hospital in, no clean clothes. And you said, Ange, I'll go to your house. I'll drive to your house and I'll get you a pair of sweatpants.
我有三个姐姐，我猜我当时太天真了。我收拾了我的小医院包，你知道的，我选好出院穿的衣服是我的紧身牛仔裤和一件可爱的小上衣。我记得。我根本穿不上那些牛仔裤，也扣不上上衣的扣子。我当时不知道自己在想什么。我literally没有衣服可以离开医院，没有干净的衣服。你说，安琪，我去你家。我开车去你家，给你拿条运动裤。
Yep. And then Jenna, you brought the sweatpants back and they also did not fit. My sweatpants didn't fit. So my friend Erin was there and she said, I'll run to the mall. There was a shopping mall like right across the way. She was like, I'll go to the mall. I was like, just get me, I guess, like a bigger pair of sweatpants. The only thing, she went pretty early in the morning.
没错。然后珍娜，你把运动裤拿回来了，结果它们也不合身。我的运动裤不合身。所以我的朋友艾琳也在那儿，她说，我去商场跑一趟。那边有个购物中心就在斜对面。她说，我去商场。我说，那就给我拿，我想，一条大一点的运动裤吧。唯一的问题是，她去得很早。
I was about to be discharged. I had no clothes. She got me a pair of sweatpants and some flip flops and a shirt. And when she gave me the bag, you guys, she had gone to Abercrombie and this is like clothing for teenagers. It had like a big printing across like the butt and the leg, right? It said like Abercrombie and I think it had number 41 on the butt. It was so embarrassing. That's what I left the hospital in.
我快要出院了。我没有衣服。她给我买了一条运动裤、几双人字拖和一件衬衫。当她把袋子给我时，你们知道吗，她去了Abercrombie，这是给青少年穿的衣服。屁股和腿上印着很大的字，对吧？上面写着Abercrombie，我想屁股上还印着数字41。太尴尬了。我就是穿着这个离开医院的。
Flip flops in these sweatpants that said 41. It was so crazy. I looked ridiculous. Well, I'll never forget being in your hospital room and the two of us just like marveling at the fact that you still had like a pregnancy belly after you gave birth to her. We're like, what is this? What the heck? I can't wear my jeans home. So I told everyone that story when we were planning this episode and I said to our costume designer, Alicia, I have to still be in my belly.
人字拖配着写有41的运动裤。太疯狂了。我看起来荒谬极了。好吧，我永远不会忘记在你病房里的情景，我们俩只是惊叹于你生完孩子后居然还挺着一个孕肚的事实。我们说，这是什么？到底怎么回事？我不能穿着牛仔裤回家了。所以在我们筹划这一集时，我把这个故事讲给所有人听，我对我们的服装设计师艾莉西亚说，我还得挺着个肚子。
You know, give me like a five month pregnant belly. Yeah, it has to be realistic. I always think maybe because I left a hospital in sweatpants that said 41 and a random top and flip flops about how the royal family does that picture after they give birth and they're in a dress with their hair blown out and they stand on the steps holding their baby. Whenever I see that, I think my photo would have been in sweatpants that said 41 and flip flops. Oh my gosh. We should get back to the episode because I have a really fun tidbit about this Michael Aaron and Kevin scene. Oh, I do too. Oh, go first.
你知道的，给我一个五个月的孕肚。是的，必须逼真。我总是在想，也许因为我是穿着写着41的运动裤、一件随意的上衣和人字拖离开医院的，而王室成员生完孩子后拍的那张照片里，他们穿着连衣裙，吹着头发，站在台阶上抱着孩子。每当我看到那个，我就想，我的照片本来应该穿着写着41的运动裤和人字拖。噢天哪。我们该回到正片了，因为关于迈克尔、艾伦和凯文的这一幕，我有一个非常有趣的八卦。哦，我也有。哦，你先说。
Well, this storyline of Aaron and Kevin having a possible romance was a pitch from none other than Brian Baumgartner. Really? Yes. So he talked about it on his podcast, Office Deep Dive, while he was interviewing Ellie Kemper, I reached out to him to confirm. And he said yes, that he can't remember exactly when he went to pitch, but he did go to the writers and say, I think that their energy is so different that they might actually make a funny couple. And he thought that kind of the slow moving Kevin versus what he called the hummingbird that was Aaron could be really fun. He said the writer said, oh, it's an interesting idea. But then he never heard anything else about it until this episode when Michael has the idea.
嗯，艾伦和凯文可能有一段罗曼史的这个故事情节，是由布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳本人提出的创意。真的吗？是的。所以他在他的播客《办公室深度解密》中谈到过这件事，当他在采访埃利·肯珀时，我联系了他进行确认。他说是的，他记不清自己是什么时候去提的建议了，但他确实去找了编剧并说，我觉得他们的能量太不同了，以至于他们实际上可能会成为一对搞笑的情侣。他觉得行动迟缓的凯文与他所谓像蜂鸟一样的艾伦之间的对比会非常有趣。他说编剧们回答说，哦，这是一个有趣的观点。但随后他就再也没听到关于它的任何消息了，直到这一集迈克尔有了这个想法。
That is so great. Well, here's my tidbit on the commentary. The writers talked about how Kevin has a joke in this episode that was their absolute favorite. They were so giddy about it. Here's what it says in the script after Michael says, you know what? I'm about to change your life. We hear loud, wet, stifled breathing from behind the door. Oh, wow.
太棒了。好吧，这是我在评论音轨里的八卦。编剧们谈到了凯文在这集里有一个笑话，那是他们绝对最喜欢的。他们对此兴奋不已。剧本里是这样写的，在迈克尔说，你知道吗？我要改变你的人生。我们听到门后传来响亮、湿润、压抑的呼吸声。哦，哇。
Aaron says, what is that sound? Michael nods at Kevin. And then the door opens and Kevin says, dada. This word, dada, made the writers laugh so hard, they thought it was brilliant that Kevin, instead of saying, tada, says, dada. They said at the table read, when it came to this part, Brian's mind auto corrected. And he read it, tada. Oh, no. And they were like, no, it's dada.
艾伦说，那是什么声音？迈克尔向凯文点了点头。然后门开了，凯文说，哒哒。这个词，哒哒，把编剧们逗得哈哈大笑，他们觉得凯文不说“塔哒”，而是说“哒哒”，这简直太机智了。他们说在围读剧本时，到了这一部分，布莱恩的大脑自动纠正了。他读成了，塔哒。哦，不。而他们当时就说，不对，是哒哒。
And they were so delighted it made it into the episode. One of my favorite lines from the scene is something that Michael says because Kevin gets really over eager to start his date like immediately. Yeah. And Michael says, you have to let the cookies cool before you pop them in your mouth. I don't know. I thought that was a really funny line. It is funny. And you also know that's from life experience.
他们太高兴这个梗能被剪进正片里了。我最喜欢这一幕中的一句台词是迈克尔说的话，因为凯文迫不及待地想要立刻开始他的约会。是的。迈克尔说，你得让饼干凉一会儿才能把它塞进嘴里。我不知道，我觉得那是一句非常搞笑的台词。确实很好笑。而且你也知道那是来自生活经验。
Back at the hospital, they are short on rooms. And they have to bring another couple in for the spare bed that is in Jim and Pam's room. It's Dale and Kathy. And Kathy is just very easily breastfeeding. Jim and Pam are in awe. And she has cute hair. I know. Real cute.
回到医院，他们的房间不够了。他们不得不把另一对夫妇安排进吉姆和帕姆房间里那张空闲的病床。那是戴尔和凯茜。而凯茜哺乳时非常轻松自如。吉姆和帕姆叹为观止。而且她的头发很可爱。我知道。真的很可爱。
I mean, they're winning over there. They are. Guest star alert. Dale was played by Evan Gustad, who you may have seen on Arrested Development or Curb Your Enthusiasm or The Good Place. And Kathy was played by Melissa Roche, who would go on to star in The Big Bang Theory. Humongous star. Yeah. Yeah.
我是说，他们在那边赢麻了。确实。客串明星警报。戴尔由埃文·古斯塔德饰演，你可能在《发展受阻》、《抑制热情》或《善地》中见过他。而凯茜则由梅丽莎·罗奇饰演，她后来主演了《生活大爆炸》。巨星。是的。是的。
But I think this was one of her very first television jobs. How crazy is that? I remember. She was so fun. Dale and Kathy's baby Caitlyn was played by Dylan and Ryland Thompson. Another set of twins. A lot is happening back at Jim and Pam's house. Yeah.
但我想这可以说是她最早的电视工作之一。多疯狂啊。我记得。她太有趣了。戴尔和凯茜的婴儿凯特琳由迪伦·汤普森和莱兰·汤普森饰演。又是一对双胞胎。吉姆和帕姆的家里正发生着很多事。是的。
Dwight and his wrecking crew are just completely demoing their kitchen. Okay. You bring up the wrecking crew. I spot Rolf. Oh, yeah. James Urbaniak. Yeah. He's there.
德怀特和他的拆迁队正在彻底拆除他们的厨房。好吧。你提到了拆迁队。我发现了罗尔夫。哦，是的。詹姆斯·乌尔巴尼亚克。是的。他在那儿。
And a woman. I find it surprising that there isn't more there. Angela, what can you tell us? Oh, I have some stuff for you. So there's nothing on the DVDs about this. There's no deleted scene. But I checked the shooting draft and there is a hilarious explanation of why Rolf and Annie, that's the character's name, is there.
还有一个女人。我觉得奇怪的是那里居然没有更多内容。安吉拉，你能告诉我们什么？哦，我有一些料要爆。所以在DVD里关于这个没有任何内容。没有被删减的场景。但我查阅了拍摄初稿，里面有一个非常搞笑的解释，说明为什么罗尔夫和安妮——那是角色的名字——会在那里。
Yes. Annie, who was played by Amy Reichelman. Here's what the script said. Interior Halpert Foyer. Morning. Dwight opens the door and finds Rolf. Behind him is the new kitchen cabinetry and Annie, a tall, quiet woman. Dwight says, you're late, Rolf.
是的，安妮由艾米·赖克尔曼饰演。剧本是这样写的。内景。哈尔珀特门厅。早晨。德怀特打开门，发现了罗尔夫。他身后是新的厨房橱柜和安妮，一个身材高大、安静的女人。德怀特说，你迟到了，罗尔夫。
Rolf looks at Annie and says, I met a woman. Dwight says, okay, but she's not using my tools. Rolf says, she has her own. Dwight's jaw drops. Rolf nods, oh, yeah. And then Dwight has a talking head where he says, Rolf dates so far out of his league it's not even funny. He is the single greatest ladies man I have ever known.
罗尔夫看着安妮说，我遇到了一个女人。德怀特说，好吧，但她不能用我的工具。罗尔夫说，她有自己的。德怀特的下巴惊掉了。罗尔夫点点头，哦，是的。然后德怀特有一个大头访问，他说，罗尔夫约会的对象段位太高了，简直不可思议。他是我见过的最伟大的女性杀手。
And I knew Amos Obshide. Mm, good ol' Amos. I know. Rolf met a woman and she brought her own tools. Wow. Mm-hmm. Well, that explains why they're there. There you go.
我还认识阿莫斯·奥布赛德。嗯，老阿莫斯。我知道。罗尔夫遇到了一个女人，她自己带了工具。哇。嗯哼。好吧，这就解释了他们为什么在那儿。就是这样。
That's Dwight's wrecking crew. Guess what it's time for. What? Clark, the lactation consultant. He's gonna arrive. He's gonna offer his services to Jim and Pam. I mean, got milk? Got milk?
那是德怀特的拆迁队。你猜该到什么环节了。什么？克拉克，母乳喂养顾问。他要来了。他要向吉姆和帕姆提供他的服务。我是说，有奶吗？有奶吗？
That's such a great line. It was so good. We are gonna go to break and then when we come back, Lee is going to join us to talk all about these scenes. But before we go to break, Angela, I just want to share that I remember that you are the person who pitched the idea of a lactation nurse. The character of a lactation nurse was not in our table read draft? Nope.
这台词太棒了。太棒了。我们要去休息一下，等我们回来，李会加入我们，和我们一起聊聊这些场景。但在我们休息之前，安吉拉，我只想分享一下，我记得你就是那个提出乳哺乳护士创意的人。围读剧本的初稿里可没有哺乳护士这个角色？没有。
But the storyline of Pam having difficulty breastfeeding was in the draft. Yeah. And you told our writers after the reading about this lactation nurse that came in and just was real handsy with your boobs. Yeah. I shared with everyone. I was like, you know, I could relate to Pam struggling to get her baby to latch. And I said, well, I had a lactation consultant.
但帕姆母乳喂养困难的故事情节在初稿里是有的。是的。读完剧本后，你跟我们的编剧讲了这个哺乳顾问的事，他进来对你的奶子动手动脚的。是的。我和大家分享了。我说，你知道的，我能感同身受帕姆努力让婴儿含住乳头的挣扎。我说，好吧，我有一个哺乳顾问。
And I explained that this person really manhandled my boobs. They really got in there. And it was a little bit awkward. Well, this prompted other people to share their stories and the writers really liked this idea of a lactation consultant. Yes. Now, mine was a woman, but they of course decided to put this very funny spin to make it a man.
我解释说这个人真的对我的奶子动粗了。他们真的上手了。而且有点尴尬。好吧，这促使其他人也分享了他们的故事，编剧们真的很喜欢这个哺乳顾问的创意。是的。现在，我那个是个女的，但他们当然决定做一个非常搞笑的改编，把她变成一个男的。
And Greg said on the commentary that they did research to see if there were male lactation nurses, and there are. And that's how we got Clark. Well, we're gonna take a break. When we come back, we will have Clark. Got milk. Hello, Lee. Hi.
格雷格在评论音轨里说，他们做过调查，看是否有男哺乳顾问，确实有。我们就是这样有了克拉克。好吧，我们要休息一下。等我们回来，我们将迎来克拉克。有奶吗。你好，李。嗨。
You're an office lady. Hello, office ladies. This is very exciting. Lee, you are sitting in my podcast closet. You know, I moved the plant in there for you to make it more pleasant. Oh, thank you. I did notice that behind me. I appreciate that.
你是办公室女士。你好，办公室女士们。这太让人兴奋了。李，你正坐在我的播客衣帽间里。你知道的，我把里面的植物挪了一下，为了让你感觉更舒适。哦，谢谢。我确实注意到我身后有这个。我很感激。
Yeah. I'm in the podcast closet today. I wish I could be there with you guys, but this is the podcast. We could do. I know. Well, we're so glad to have you. And now, Jenna, you get to see what you look like when you zoom in. Yes.
是的。我今天在播客衣帽间里。我希望我能和你们在一起，但这不就是播客嘛。我们可以。我知道。好吧，我们很高兴有你加入。现在，珍娜，你可以看到你缩放时的样子了。是的。
How's our little gal? She's good. She's good. We just went for a walk. We took Maggie for a walk. And now she is watching some TV and drinking lots of water. Oh, good. Thanks for taking care of her.
我们的小宝贝怎么样？她很好。她很好。我们刚去散步了。我们带着玛吉去散步了。现在她正在看电视，喝很多水。哦，太好了。谢谢你照顾她。
Can I say something before we begin? Yes. I just wanted to say congratulations on this because, you know, I've been there since the beginning, obviously, I've seen the seeds of this podcast and, and I've watched you guys grow it. And I see how hard you work at it. I mean,
在我们开始之前我能说句话吗？可以。我只是想对这个表达祝贺，因为，你知道的，我从一开始就在场，很明显，我看到了这个播客的萌芽，而且，我看着你们把它发展壮大。我看到你们为之付出了多少努力。我是说，
the listeners should know these ladies put so much heart and love into this podcast and so much effort. I mean, there's research and there's outlines and there's so much, so much watching of episodes. And Jenna walks around the house with her headphones on listening to episodes because she's going to edit the episode. It's really impressive. Anyway, congratulations.
听众们应该知道，这两位女士为这个播客投入了如此多的心血、爱意和精力。我是说，有做研究，有做大纲，还有看了那么多的剧集。珍娜戴着耳机在房子里走来走去听剧集，因为她要剪辑这集播客。真的很让人印象深刻。总之，恭喜你们。
This is a phenomenal thing you guys have created. And you deserve all the, all the, all the accolades. Thank you. Thank you so much, Lee. That means a lot. I feel like you and Josh, whenever you get together, I always like, it makes me happy because I see you both being like, I know with the headphones walking around the house.
这是你们创造的一个了不起的成就。你们配得上所有的荣誉。谢谢。非常感谢你，李。这对我意义重大。我觉得你和乔什，每当你们聚在一起时，我总是觉得，这让我很高兴，因为我看到你们两个都像——我知道那种戴着耳机在房子里走来走去的感觉。
It's true. It's like, it's like, you know, like how you have a sibling and you both know what it's like to have the same parent. It's kind of Josh and I are like, we have that thing with you guys. We're like, we know what it's like to have the wives doing the podcast and the book, by the way. Yeah.
真的。这就像是，就像是，你知道的，就像你有一个兄弟姐妹，你们都知道拥有同一个父母是什么感觉。这就是乔什和我的状态，我们和你们也有这种感觉。我们就像是，我们知道老婆们做播客和写书是什么感觉，顺便说一句。是的。
It's about Jenna was over the other day. She was like, mom, I, is Jenna here? I was like, oh no, I'm, I'm just listening to our podcast and editing in the bathroom. She thought you would come over to look at outfits with me. Aw. Well, Lee, thank you so much. That was so sweet of you to say.
就是关于珍娜前几天过来时。她就像是，妈妈，我，珍娜在这儿吗？我说，哦不，我，我只是在卫生间里听我们的播客并进行剪辑。她以为你是来跟我一起看衣服的。噢。好吧，李，非常感谢你。你说得太甜了。
I didn't know he was going to say that. I know. It's very nice. Well, I guess we should start where we usually start. We always ask our guests, how did you get your job on the office? But maybe I should kick this one off because. Did he know someone? Yeah.
我不知道他会这么说。我知道。非常nice。好吧，我想我们应该从老地方开始。我们总是问嘉宾，你是怎么在《办公室》找到工作的？但也许我应该先开这个头。因为。他认识什么人吗？是的。
Was there like a connection with someone on the cast or crew? Well, when the writers came up with this storyline of the lactation consultant, Paul Lieberstein approached me, got me aside and said, hey, Jenna, we have this really funny idea, but it involves a man kind of like squishing your breasts around. How do you feel about that? Like that would be a guest actor.
是不是和演员或剧组里的某个人有什么联系？好吧，当编剧们想出哺乳顾问这个故事情节时，保罗·利伯斯坦找到我，把我拉到一边说，嘿，珍娜，我们有一个非常搞笑的创意，但它涉及一个男人有点像揉捏你的胸部。你对此有什么感觉？就像那是客串演员一样。
Are you okay with it? And I said, well, I think it would be maybe a little awkward now that you mentioned it. And he said, well, what if that person was your fiancee Lee? What if Lee did it? And so then I came home and I told you that. And I guess you can take it from here. Yeah, you came home.
你觉得可以吗？我说，好吧，既然你这么说，我觉得可能确实有点尴尬。他说，那如果那个人是你的未婚夫李呢？如果让李来演呢？然后我回家把这事告诉你了。我想你可以从这里接下去讲了。是的，你回家了。
You told me, I thought it sounded pretty funny. And I said, sure, right? So of course they weren't just handing me the job. I had to go into Alice and Jones and read for the role or sort of prove that I could do it. Which I got to say, if there was ever a layup in the audition world, I mean, this was, this was like a six foot hoop that was like, just please drop the ball in the basket and make everyone's
你告诉我了，我觉得听起来挺搞笑的。我说，当然可以，对吧？所以他们当然不是直接把工作塞给我。我得去艾莉森·琼斯那里为这个角色试读，或者说证明我能胜任。我必须得说，如果试镜界有什么送分题的话，我是说，这就像是一个六英尺高的篮框，上面写着，求求你把球投进篮筐里，让所有人的
life easier, you know? So, you know, obviously there was no one else reading for it. So I went in, I read for the role. It seemed to go fine. I had a good time. And I got the part. Well, Lee, on the commentary, they said that you crushed the audition.
生活都变得更轻松吧，你知道的？所以，你知道，很明显没有其他人来试读这个角色。所以我去了，我试读了这个角色。一切似乎都很顺利。我过得很愉快。然后我就得到了这个角色。好吧，李，在评论音轨里，他们说你在试镜时表现惊艳。
They said they loved how just like business you were like as Clark, like, you know, you just came in, do your thing. And when they were rewatching the scene, they said they loved how you would pump the hand sanitizer as you left or as you came up each time and just crack them up. That hand sanitizer was like my go to little, you know, that was like my security blanket in the scene. Like if I didn't know what to do, I just go pump some more hand
他们说他们非常喜欢你扮演克拉克时那种公事公办的样子，你知道的，你就是走进来，做你该做的事。当他们重温这一幕时，他们说他们超爱你在离开或每次走近时都会按压免洗手消毒液的动作，简直把他们笑死。那个手消毒液就像是我的招牌小动作，你知道的，那就像是那个场景中的安全毯。如果我不知道该做什么，我就去再按一点
sanitizer. It was great. I love that detail. Well, I have a follow-up question. You know, you'd been to set before. You had visited me many times. You knew everybody. You had hung out with us.
手消毒液。太棒了。我太喜欢这个细节了。好吧，我有一个后续问题。你知道的，你以前去过片场。你拜访过我很多次。你认识每个人。你和我们一起闲逛过。
What was it like coming on the show this time as an actor instead of a visitor? Well, let's see. That's a good question. I had been up a few times to eat lunch, I remember. And we would always just kind of eat lunch and then hang out in your trailer and then you'd go to work and I would leave as usually how it was, Jenna.
这次作为演员而不是访客来到剧组，感觉怎么样？嗯，让我想想。这是个好问题。我上去过几次吃午饭，我记得。我们通常就是吃午饭，然后去你的房车里闲逛，然后你去工作，我就离开了，通常情况就是这样，珍娜。
And so this time I had my own trailer. Yeah. Yeah. They gave me a trailer. Were you like, come to my trailer, babe? It was a tiny thing. I looked in there for, I just kind of opened the door. I saw Clark on the, you know, on the outside.
所以这次我有我自己的房车了。是的。是的。他们给我安排了一辆房车。你会不会说，来我的房车呀，宝贝？那是个极小的玩意儿。我在里面待了——我只是把门推开了一条缝。我在外面看到了克拉克，你知道的。
I opened up and looked in. It was the smallest thing. I was like, I'm going to go to Janice trailer. So I never used the trailer. It was a waste of money for NBC. Sorry about that. But, um, but no, I, I, I remember, um, you know, coming up, I felt a little nervous, you know, um, obviously, um,
我推开门看了一眼。那是最小的玩意儿。我想说，我要去珍娜的房车。所以我从没用过那个房车。这简直是NBC在浪费钱。对此我很抱歉。但是，嗯，但是不，我，我记得，嗯，走上去的时候，我感觉有点紧张，你知道，嗯，很明显，嗯，
but one thing that I remember was that I had, I had been to set a number of times, but I'd never seen the camera rolling. You know, I would, we'd hang out and then I'd leave when you'd go back to work. So, so this time I got to see, you know, Jenna, you and John, um, as Jim and Pam. And I was super impressed.
但我记得的一件事是，我虽然去过片场好几次，但我从没见过摄像机在滚动。你知道的，我们以前总是闲逛，然后等你回去工作时我就离开了。所以，这次我能看到，你知道的，珍娜，你和约翰，嗯，作为吉姆和帕姆在演戏。我超级震撼。
I mean, you guys just made it look so easy. It was so seamless. That was a real exciting moment for me. And all I thought was, I hope I can, you know, hold my own in the scene with these two. Well, you totally did. And you are an amazing actor and writer. I thought the whole scene was like watching these three like
我是说，你们俩把它演得太轻松了。太天衣无缝了。那对当时的我是个非常激动的时刻。我脑子里想的全是，希望我能在和这两个人的对手戏中，你知道，Hold住场面。好吧，你完全做到了。而且你是一个了不起的演员和作家。我觉得整场戏看起来就像是在看三个喜剧
comedy geniuses. I loved every second of it. Oh, thank you. Thank you. I have a question for you. Little actory kind of question. Jenna loves these kinds of questions. Lee, did you do anything to prepare for the role of Clark?
天才在飙戏。我喜欢其中的每一秒。哦，谢谢。谢谢你。我有一个问题要问你。有点演员类型的问题。珍娜最喜欢这种问题了。李，你为了克拉克的角色做了什么准备吗？
What was your process? It was my process. Yes. I don't think I did very much. I mean, I, I sort of looked up what a lactation consultant was, you know, and you guys didn't have kids yet. No, we did not have kids. And I, I really remember telling Jenna quite a lot about my lactation consultant.
你的创作过程是什么样的？我的过程吗？是的。我觉得我没做太多。我是说，我，我大概查了一下什么是哺乳顾问，你知道的，而且你们当时还没孩子。不，我们当时还没有孩子。而且我真的记得跟珍娜聊了很多关于我的哺乳顾问的事。
Well, it's funny because it's funny to say that because we did not have kids then. So I never experienced a lactation consultant or the saga of breastfeeding up till then, you know, so, so I remember looking back, I think I probably had, I known how difficult breastfeeding can be. And had I met some lactation consultants, I probably would have played Clark a little differently because, you know, once we had
好吧，这很有趣，因为这样说很有意思，因为我们当时还没有孩子。所以在那之前我从未经历过哺乳顾问或母乳喂养的传奇故事，你知道的，所以，所以我觉得回过头来看，我当时如果知道母乳喂养可以有多困难。如果我遇到过一些哺乳顾问，我可能会把克拉克演得稍微有点不同，因为，你知道的，一旦我们有了
kids and, and, and, you know, Jenna was breastfeeding both of them and we were learning how it is. And it could be very stressful and difficult. And then you meet these lactation consultants that come in and build with empathy. And they're just, you know, they know that the, the, the mom is stressed out and they just have this, this, you know, they're oozing empathy.
孩子，然后，然后，你知道的，珍娜一直在给他们两个哺乳，我们在学习这是怎么回事。这可能会非常 stressful（有压力）且困难。然后你会遇到那些走进来并充满同理心的哺乳顾问。他们就是，你知道的，他们知道妈妈压力很大，然后他们身上就散发出这种，你知道的，他们浑身都散发着同理心。
And I probably would have played Clark with a little more of that, you know, if I had I known, I probably would have given him a little bit more of, you know, hmm, got milk, you know, changes that line. It does. But, but now I just decided to play him very straight. You know, I knew the joke, the joke was, here's a male lactation consultant and the humor is going to come from, from Jim's
我要是早知道的话，我演克拉克时大概会多带一点那种……你知道的，我要是知道了，我大概会多给他一点那种，嗯，来杯牛奶的感觉，你知道的，改一下那句台词。确实。但是，现在我决定非常正经地演他。你知道的，我知道那个笑话，笑话就是，这里有个男性母乳喂养顾问，而幽默感将来自于吉姆
reaction to that. And so I just kind of, I just tried to lay the pipe there and let, let John do, do all the heavy lifting. They, they did say on the DVD commentary, there were props that were like lactation consultant pamphlets, like actual pamphlets, real ones. And they, they said you were reading them. Yeah, I did.
对此的反应。所以我只是试着在那儿铺垫一下，让约翰去承担所有的重活。他们确实在DVD评论音轨里说过，有道具就像是母乳喂养顾问的小册子，就像真的一样的小册子，真正的。而且他们说你在看那些。对，我看了。
I did pick up some and read them and like, okay, look at this, there's the sea, there's the sea on the, on the breast there, the guy making the sea. So. Okay. Yeah. Um, I remember that because you and John were friends that John was really trying to make you laugh a lot.
我的确拿了一些来看，然后心想，好吧，看这个，那里有个C，乳房那里有个C，那家伙在做C的手势。所以。好吧。嗯，我记得那个，因为你和约翰是朋友，约翰真的很想让你笑个不停。
Like he was, he was like coming for you. Yeah. He was laying it on pretty good. And it was really, it was hard. It was hard to, to, to not break. If I looked over at him because he was, he'd hold that pamphlet up and just his eyes. Would he cover it?
就像他在，他就像是冲着你来的。对。他演得相当不错。而且真的，真的很艰难，很难，很难，不笑场。如果我看着他，因为他会把那个小册子举起来，只露出他的眼睛。他会遮住它吗？
Yeah. And it was hard not to break, but we did. I think we did break a few times. Didn't we Jenna? We did. Yeah. It was, it was difficult cause he was definitely, he was milking it.
对，而且很难不笑场，但我们确实笑了。我想我们确实笑场了好几次。对吧，珍娜？我们确实笑了。对。这很难，因为他绝对是在，他在借题发挥。
Oh Lord. There it is. Yeah. Boom. Lee, I'm curious. What do you remember most about your day of shooting on the office? Do you have a favorite memory?
哦，天哪。就是这样。没错。太棒了。李，我很好奇。关于你在《办公室》拍摄的那天，你印象最深的是什么？你有什么最喜欢的记忆吗？
I mean, Harold Ramis. Okay. Well, actually, I don't know if you guys have mentioned this, but we, we shot this scene on Groundhog Day. Do you remember that? We have not mentioned it. Yes. It was incredible.
我是说，哈罗德·雷米斯。好吧。其实，我不知道你们有没有提到过这个，但我们拍这场戏的那天是土拨鼠日。你还记得吗？我们没有提到过。是的。这太不可思议了。
The director of Groundhog Day, the movie Harold Ramis was directing us on Groundhog Day. I remember that starting in the morning, we were all just like, when can we go up to Harold? When can we say something? Happy Groundhog Day. Well, I remember when you went up to him, we all had sort of, I think everyone was thinking it.
《土拨鼠日》的导演，电影导演哈罗德·雷米斯在土拨鼠日那天指导我们。我记得从早上开始，我们大家就都在想，我们什么时候能去找哈罗德？我们什么时候能说点什么？土拨鼠日快乐。嗯，我记得你去找他的时候，我们大家都有点，我想每个人心里都在想。
And finally you said it. And when he started to talk about Groundhog Day, everyone just kind of came over. We all just moved over and just sat there and listened to him talk about it. It was really, really fun, really exciting. He was amazing like that. There was a day we all talked to him about Ghostbusters,
最后你说了出来。当他开始谈论土拨鼠日时，大家就都围了过来。我们所有人都挪过去，坐在那儿听他讲。真的非常非常有趣，非常激动人心。他就是那样令人惊叹。有一天我们都跟他聊了《捉鬼敢死队》，
but he was just so, so cool. I was bummed because I wasn't working that day. And I remember Jenna calling me and saying, and I worked with Harold Ramis on Groundhog Day. Like you geeked out about it. Well, speaking of Ghostbusters, I remember that day too, because that's when he told us that every Halloween, he dressed up in his Ghostbusters costume to hand out candy.
但他就是那么那么酷。我很沮丧，因为那天我没有戏份。我记得珍娜打电话给我说，我和哈罗德·雷米斯在《土拨鼠日》里合作过。就像你对此感到极度狂热一样。嗯，说到《捉鬼敢死队》，我也记得那天，因为那是他告诉我们，每个万圣节他都会穿上他的捉鬼敢死队服装来发糖果。
He said kids would ring the front doorbell and he would be in full Ghostbuster suit. And he gave out full candy bars. Yeah. How cool is that? I know. That's the coolest house on the block right there. All right.
他说孩子们会按前门的门铃，而他会穿着全套捉鬼敢死队制服。而且他发的是整块的巧克力棒。对。这有多酷？我知道。那绝对是这条街上最酷的房子。好了。
I have to ask you about a moment, you guys. There's the scene where Clark tells Pam to flick her nipple. We got a lot, a lot of mail about the flick your nipple moment. Breanna Kay from Texas wrote in and said, four years ago, I gave birth to my first daughter. When the lactation consultant came in to check on our breast feeding progress, she asked if I knew how to stimulate the nipple. I said, absolutely.
我得问你们一个时刻，伙计们。有个场景是克拉克叫帕姆弹她的乳头。我们收到了很多很多关于弹乳头那个时刻的信件。来自德克萨斯州的布里安娜·凯写信说，四年前，我生下了我的第一个女儿。当母乳喂养顾问进来查看我们的母乳喂养进展时，她问我是否知道如何刺激乳头。我说，当然。
And I started to flick my nipple. No. She was appalled and asked, where did you learn that? And I very seriously told her I learned it from an episode of The Office. She thought it was so funny. She even brought in another nurse and had me repeat the flicking, which they both found hysterical.
然后我开始弹我的乳头。不会吧。她惊呆了，问我这是从哪学来的。我非常严肃地告诉她，我是从一集《办公室》里学到的。她觉得太好笑了。她甚至叫来了另一名护士，让我重复那个弹乳头的动作，她们两个都觉得这滑稽极了。
Then they instructed me to roll the nipple instead of flicking it. This is a true story. Wow. I love that. Is that great? No. Well, I remember when we were doing that scene, none of that stuff at a certain point was scripted.
然后她们指示我揉捏乳头而不是弹它。这是个真实的故事。哇。我喜欢这个。是不是很棒？不。嗯，我记得我们在拍那场戏的时候，到了一定程度，那些东西全都是即兴发挥的。
The writers on set were just throwing out phrases for you to say or for me to say to get reactions out of John. Yeah. No, we went through a few, we went through like tap the nipple, you know, hit the nipple, but I think flick was the one that really did it, you know, and I can't remember if I was actually flicking, you know,
片场的编剧们只是抛出一些短语让你说，或者让我说，以此来激起约翰的反应。对。不，我们试了好几个，我们试过拍打乳头，你知道的，击打乳头，但我认为弹才是真正起作用的那一个，你知道的，而且我记不清我当时是不是真的在弹，
the nipple, but. I don't remember, Lee. I'm so sorry. Sorry if I was. I apologize if I was. I was caught up in the moment. You know, you were really though, handsy there.
你知道的，乳头，但是。我不记得了，李。真的非常抱歉。如果我做了的话对不起。如果我做了的话我道歉。我当时太入戏了。你知道的，你在那里真的很放肆。
Like you were really manhandling my breasts in the scene and because they wanted to see all that. Like, I was going to ask you guys that because I was like, you know, a lot of times, as actors, we just cheat it, right? We cheat everything. We will cheat a kiss or an embrace just for boundaries and
就像你在那个场景里真的在对我的胸部动手动脚，因为他们想看到所有这些。就像，我本来想问你们这个，因为我想，你知道，很多时候，作为演员，我们只是借位，对吧？我们所有东西都借位。我们借位接吻或拥抱，仅仅是为了保持界限和
whatnot. But I was like, it really looks like there's some boob play happening here. There was. Yeah. I mean, that's why I got the job. So,
诸如此类的东西。但我觉得，这里真的看起来有在摸胸啊。确实有。对。我是说，这就是我得到这份工作的原因。所以，
you know, why does we'll go for the reality? Well, it was perfect because it really sold out. Well, it was perfect because it really sold the moment and Jim's reaction was so great. There is a deleted scene where Jim shares about Pam's feelings for Clark.
你知道的，为什么我们不追求真实感呢？嗯，这太完美了，因为它真的很卖力。嗯，这太完美了，因为它完美呈现了那个时刻，吉姆的反应太棒了。有一个被删减的片段，吉姆分享了帕姆对克拉克的感情。
It's a talking head. He's standing outside of your hospital room, but you know, there's a window in the door and you can see Clark and Pam over Jim's shoulder and you have to hear it. Like most couples, Pam and I have that one person that we're allowed to hook up with if the opportunity ever arises.
这是一个面对镜头的独白。他站在你的病房外面，但是你知道的，门上有个窗户，你可以从吉姆的肩膀上方看到克拉克和帕姆，你得听见声音。就像大多数情侣一样，我和帕姆也有那样一个人，如果机会出现的话，我们是被允许和这个人发生关系的。
Mine is Cameron Diaz. And hers, coincidentally enough, was Clark from the hospital. How does it feel when I do that? It feels good. Well, that's my kid.
我的是卡梅隆·迪亚兹。而她的，说来也巧，是医院里的克拉克。我这么做感觉怎么样？感觉很好。嗯，那是我的孩子。
Amazing. I don't even remember that. I have to look at that deleted scene. I don't remember doing that. Well, you guys are behind the door, you know, but he can hear you and see you. I see.
太神奇了。我甚至都不记得这个了。我得去看看那个删减片段。我不记得我拍过这个。嗯，你们在门后面，你知道的，但他能听见你们也能看见你们。原来如此。
And then he dives back in the room when Clark's like, how does that feel? And Pam goes, feels good. He's like, Matt, that's, I'm going back in. That's so good. One of my favorite parts of the episode is when Cece falls off her latch right after Clark leaves
然后当克拉克说“感觉怎么样”，帕姆说“感觉很好”时，他又冲回了房间。他就像是，马特，那是，我要回去了。这太棒了。这集我最喜欢的片段之一是塞西在克拉克离开后不久从含乳姿势上滑脱下来，
and Jim is like, let me try it. Let me try it. And she's like, no, babe, I just think that would be weird. Get Clark. Yeah. Oh my gosh.
然后吉姆说，让我试试。让我试试。然后她说，不，宝贝，我只是觉得那会很怪。去找克拉克。对。哦，天哪。
It was just so much fun being with you on set, Lee. It was like you used to always visit me and it was just a social visit. But having you on the episode, it was an opportunity to share with you from the inside. This thing I had been doing for six years. It was really cool. And of course you're going to come back later
和你一起在片场真的太有趣了，李。就像你以前总是来看我，那只是一次社交访问。但能让你参演这一集，这是一个机会，让我能从内部和你分享我做了六年的这件事。这真的很酷。而且你当然会回来，
and direct an episode in season nine. We'll have to have you in the studio for that. Yes. Yes. Hopefully no children will be sick that day and I'll be able to join you ladies. I know. I know.
在第九季里导演一集。到时我们得请你来录音室做客。好。好。希望那天没有孩子生病，我能加入你们这些女士。我知道。我知道。
But it was really special having you there. I cherish this memory. Yeah, me too. It was really fun. And I knew everybody and everyone was so welcoming and made it so easy for me. Which was helpful because I'm sure I was a little nervous walking in,
但有你在真的很特别。我珍视这段记忆。对，我也是。这真的很有趣。而且我都认识，每个人都那么热情，让我觉得轻松自在。这很有帮助，因为我确信我走进去时有点紧张，
didn't want to screw things up and it was so fun. It was a great time. I was about to get to do it. Well, as your friendly, it was so fun for me to rewatch this and to see you and Jenna, you guys have great chemistry and you've worked together on other projects. Giant Mechanical Man is an amazing movie that Leigh wrote
不想把事情搞砸，而且这真的很有趣。这是一段美好的时光。我正要去做这件事。好吧，作为你的朋友，我重看这一集觉得太有趣了，看到你和珍娜，你们两个很有化学反应，而且你们在其他项目里也合作过。《巨人机械人》是一部由李编剧
and directed and Jenna sent it and you should all go watch it. There's my plug. Thank you. That's how we fell in love. It's one of my favorite movies. Thank you. But is there anything you're working on right now that you can share with us?
并执导的精彩电影，珍娜发过它，你们都应该去看。这是我的私货广告。谢谢。这就是我们相爱的方式。这是我最喜欢的电影之一。谢谢。但是你现在有什么正在进行、可以跟我们分享的项目吗？
Oh, thanks, Angie. Yeah, actually I have a horror film that I wrote that we're going to shoot in the fall, I believe, that I'm actually going to act in a little bit too. Sam right now is doing fist pump. Nice. Nice. And then the other fun thing is I know you had Billy Joe on,
哦，谢谢，安吉。是的，其实我写了一部恐怖片，我想我们会在秋天开拍，而且我也打算在里面稍微演一下。萨姆现在在做振臂欢呼的手势。太棒了。太棒了。然后另一件有趣的事是，我知道你们请过比利·乔，
but Billy Joe Armstrong and I are working on a project together as well, which is really fun. Which will be your second project with Billy Joe Armstrong. You know, after that episode aired, people were like, how do you know Billy Joe Armstrong? And I mean, the truth is that Leigh is good friends with Billy Joe Armstrong because Leigh wrote and directed a film starring Billy Joe called Ordinary World,
但比利·乔·阿姆斯特朗和我也在合作一个项目，这真的很有趣。这将是你和比利·乔·阿姆斯特朗的第二个合作项目。你知道的，那集播出后，人们都在问，你怎么认识比利·乔·阿姆斯特朗的？我的意思是，事实是李和比利·乔·阿姆斯特朗是好朋友，因为李编剧并执导了一部由比利·乔主演的电影叫《平常世界》，
and I have just sort of glommed on that friendship is what it is. And here's another office connection. Brian Bonkartner is in that movie. Yes. Yes, he is. Brian has an amazing speech in that movie about Scotch. It's one of my favorite parts of the film.
而我只是顺便搭上了这份友谊，就是这样。这里还有另一个《办公室》的梗。布赖恩·鲍姆加特纳也演了那部电影。是的。是的，他演了。布赖恩在那部电影里有一段关于苏格兰威士忌的精彩演讲。这是我最喜欢的部分之一。
Oh, yeah. Oh, Leigh, we can't wait to check all of that out and we can't wait to have you back on. Thanks, ladies. This was really fun. I love you, babe. I'll see you in like an hour and a half when I get home. Okay.
哦，对。哦，李，我们迫不及待地想去看看所有这些，我们也迫不及待地想让你再次做客。谢谢，女士们。这真的很有趣。我爱你，宝贝。我大概一个半小时后到家就能见到你了。好的。
See you in a bit. Have fun. Bye. Bye. Well, where should we go next, Angela? I would say to accounting. Mm-hmm. Because Angela is on the phone.
一会儿见。玩得开心。拜拜。拜拜。好吧，安吉拉，我们接下来该去哪？我会说去会计部。嗯哼。因为安吉拉在打电话。
She's got a lot of eye shadow on again today. She's visioned it up. Mm-hmm. And color. Mm-hmm. She wants to know if Dwight has revised their contract. And he has. He has crossed the T's and dotted the I's and the umlots
她今天又化了很浓的眼影。她盛装打扮了。嗯哼。而且涂了颜色。嗯哼。她想知道德怀特有没有修改他们的合同。他修改了。他字斟句酌，把所有的细节都敲定好了，
and it's time to go. They're going to meet up later. They're going to meet at exactly mid-late afternoon. Mm-hmm. I love Angela and Dwight scenes. They're so weird. One thing I think we should mention is that that lunch date with Erin and Kevin, it did not go great.
是时候行动了。他们稍后会碰面。他们会在下午中后期准时碰面。嗯哼。我喜欢安吉拉和德怀特的对手戏。他们太古怪了。我觉得我们应该提到的一件事是，艾琳和凯文的那场午餐约会，进展得并不顺利。
They were not hitting it off. No. Andy was spying on them through a plant. Yeah. They were spying on them. Erin is going to have to approach Kevin's desk and try and let him down easy. The scene is so awkward.
他们并没有擦出火花。没有。安迪一直在通过一株植物监视他们。对。他们在监视他们。艾琳将不得不走到凯文的桌前，试图委婉地拒绝他。这个场景太尴尬了。
Of course it's awkward. Michael's a part of it. Erin just keeps using the word friend. Andy is eavesdropping behind another plant. And Kevin is not getting it. So Michael is going to step in and he's going to explain that it's not going to happen, Kevin. Mm-hmm.
当然尴尬了。迈克尔也参与其中。艾琳一直用“朋友”这个词。安迪在另一株植物后面偷听。而凯文根本没领会到。所以迈克尔要介入了，他要解释说这不可能发生，凯文。嗯哼。
And then we're going to go back to the hospital. It's nighttime. Jim and Pam are snuggled in her bed. The baby starts crying. Yeah. Jim sort of half awake grabs the baby. Mm-hmm. It lashes.
然后我们要回到医院。已经是晚上了。吉姆和帕姆依偎在她的床上。宝宝开始哭了。对。吉姆半梦半醒地抱起宝宝。嗯哼。它含住了。
It does. They're doing it. They're really parents now. So sweet. Isabella is going to arrive and she would like to hold the baby, but Pam just wants to burp it first. And that's when she realizes. Wrong baby.
确实含住了。他们做到了。他们真的是父母了。太甜了。伊莎贝拉要来了，她想抱抱宝宝，但帕姆只想先给她拍嗝。也就是在这个时候她意识到。抱错孩子了。
Wrong baby. The wrong baby. Her baby is laying next to her and it's Crib. Whose baby? Oh, Lord. It's Kathy's baby. It's Kathy's baby and she's just breastfed it. Lady, we could not get through wrong baby.
抱错孩子了。抱错孩子了。她的宝宝正躺在她旁边的小床里。那是谁的孩子？哦，天哪。那是凯茜的孩子。那是凯茜的孩子，而她刚刚给它喂了奶。天哪，我们简直无法演完抱错孩子这场戏。
Were you guys so tickled? This line, wrong baby, just made us break so much. Charlie Grandy, the writer of this episode, shared that it was Jean Stupnitsky that pitched Pam should breastfeed the wrong baby. He had originally had the idea that somehow Michael would be the cause of mixing up the babies, but ultimately they couldn't figure out a way to get Michael
你们当时是不是觉得太逗了？这句台词，“抱错孩子了”，让我们笑到彻底崩溃。这一集的编剧查理·格兰迪透露，是吉恩·斯普尼斯基提出让帕姆去给错的宝宝喂奶。他原本的想法是某种程度上由迈克尔导致婴儿被调包，但最终他们想不出什么办法能让迈克尔
back into the hospital room, but they still loved the idea of wrong baby. So this is how they pulled it off. I bought it. I bought it like you're sort of tired. You wheeled a little rolly crib over to your bed. You're not really paying attention. I also loved in the scene when they realized it's the wrong
回到病房里，但他们仍然很喜欢抱错孩子这个点子。所以他们就是这样实现的。我信了。我信了，就像你有点累一样。你把一个小移动婴儿床推到了你的床边。你根本没太注意。我也很喜欢那个场景，当他们意识到抱错了
baby and they quickly put the baby back in its crib in the way that John sort of just pushed it. I know. John as Jim sort of pushed it and then like cradled into you. That was making us laugh too. We loved the slow, cartoonish image of this baby rolling back to its real parent. The next morning, Josie, the nurse is going to ask Pam and Jim
孩子，然后迅速把孩子放回婴儿床里时，约翰那种直接推过去的方式。我知道。约翰饰演的吉姆随手一推，然后把你揽在怀里。这也把我们逗笑了。我们太喜欢这个缓慢的、滑稽的画面了，这个宝宝滚回了它真正的父母身边。第二天早上，护士若西问帕姆和吉姆
if they're excited to go home. And they're like, we have half an hour here. More. And she's like, well, 25 minutes. Oh, it's a sass trade. My favorite one is when she asked Jim if he has the car seat and he says, yes, it's right over there. And she says the bottom part is supposed to be in the car.
他们是不是很高兴要回家了。而他们却说，我们在这儿还有半小时。更多。她说，好吧，25分钟。哦，这是在斗嘴。我最喜欢的一幕是她问吉姆有没有带安全座椅，他说，有，就在那儿。她说底座应该装在车里。
And he says, I have a news flash for you. The whole thing goes in the car. There was an alt joke for this scene. The writer said in the commentary that they had written a scene where Kevin installs the car seat for Jim and he puts it in the driver's seat. Oh my gosh. I remember that.
而他说，我告诉你们一个突发新闻。整个东西都要装在车里。这一场戏本来还有一个备选笑话。编剧在评论音轨里说，他们写过一个场景，凯文帮吉姆安装安全座椅，结果他把它装在了驾驶员座位上。哦，天哪。我记得那个。
That is funny. Well, they do leave the hospital. I would like to point out something. Pam is leaving in her own coat, her gray coat and not Creed's plaid coat that she went to the hospital in. Nice catch. You're welcome. Pam is being wheeled out of the hospital by an orderly who kind
太搞笑了。不过他们确实离开了医院。我想指出一件事。帕姆离开时穿的是她自己的外套，她的灰色外套，而不是她去医院时穿的克里德的格子外套。观察入微。不客气。帕姆坐着轮椅被护工推出医院，这个护工还
of shames Jim for not pulling the car around. Yeah. It's like most dads pull the car around. Yeah. Way to go. Guest star alert, the orderly that helps Pam out of her wheelchair is Keisha Giles. Pam gets out of the wheelchair.
因为吉姆没有把车开过来而有点数落他。对。就像大多数爸爸都会把车开过来一样。对。干得好。客串明星警报，帮帕姆坐轮椅的护工是基沙·贾尔斯。帕姆从轮椅上站起来。
She goes to sit on a nearby bench and Cece sort of immediately starts crying. And Pam is alone on this bench with her baby who is crying. She has all of this anxiety. Right. The baby isn't latching. The baby is crying. Well, in the end, as Jim is kind of coming back, the baby latches
她走到一张长椅上坐下，塞西几乎立刻就开始哭了。帕姆独自一人带着她哭泣的宝宝坐在长椅上。她充满了焦虑。对。宝宝没有含住乳头。宝宝在哭。嗯，最后，当吉姆走回来时，宝宝含住了乳头，
and they have this really beautiful moment on the bench together. And you say this line as Pam, but I could only just hear it as you because I've heard you say stuff like this before. You went, we did it. And it's so cute. I just love that. I know there's been many times you and I have tackled something really tough and you've turned to me and you've said, we did it.
他们在长椅上度过了非常美好的时刻。而你作为帕姆说出了这句台词，但我听起来只觉得那就是你，因为我以前听过你说过类似的话。你说了，我们做到了。这太可爱了。我只是好喜欢这个。我知道有很多次你和我一起克服了非常艰难的事情，你转过身对我说，我们做到了。
And I just heard my friend in that moment. You know, I was looking at the shooting draft and when we got to the scene, I realized there was a much bigger version of the scene and it's crazy. Oh yeah, this scene on the bench. I have a whole story about it. This was actually a reshoot. Well, that makes sense because the scene in the shooting draft,
在那一刻我听到了我朋友的声音。你知道，我当时在看拍摄剧本，当我们拍到这一幕时，我意识到这个场景还有一个大得多的版本，这太疯狂了。哦，对，长椅上的这场戏。我有一个完整的故事。这其实是一次补拍。嗯，这就说得通了，因为拍摄剧本里的那个场景，
it really threw me for a loop. I have it. Do you want me to read it? Yes, read it. Okay, guys. Buckle in. Exterior hospital. Spy shot.
真的把我弄糊涂了。我有剧本。你想让我读一下吗？好，读吧。好的，伙计们。系好安全带。医院外部。偷拍镜头。
Pam is on a bench with the baby. People pass by. She looks down at the crying baby. She looks around, puts on the nursing blanket and presents her breast to the baby. Pam says, come on. I got good breasts. I got milk in here for you.
帕姆抱着宝宝坐在长椅上。人们从旁走过。她低头看着哭泣的宝宝。她四处看了看，戴上哺乳巾，把乳房露出来给宝宝。帕姆说，来吧。我有好乳房。我这里有奶给你。
I got good stuff in here. Don't you like my titties? Is this about that cup of coffee I had in the second trimester? Give me a break. I'm trying here. Are you going to bust my balls your whole life? Pam looks around to make sure the camera is not around, but we have very good hiding spots.
我这里有好东西。难道你不喜欢我的胸部吗？这难道是因为我在孕中期喝的那杯咖啡吗？饶了我吧。我在努力呢。你打算一辈子都跟我过不去吗？帕姆四处看了看以确保摄像机不在附近，但我们有非常好的藏身之处。
Pam starts to sing Brahms Lullaby. Have a drink. Have a drink. Come on, little Cecilia. I've got milk here in my titay. It's something that tastes good. Grab a hold here. Get your drink on.
帕姆开始唱勃拉姆斯的摇篮曲。喝吧。喝吧。来吧，小塞西莉亚。我的胸部里有奶。这味道很好。含住这里。开始喝吧。
Come on. Latch your stupid mouth. Oh, you're getting it. Yes. The baby responds and for the first time, Pam relaxes. Something changes in her face and she seems happy. Jim pulls up and gets out. Jenna, I read this and I was like, what?
来吧。含住你那愚蠢的小嘴。哦，你含住了。太棒了。宝宝有了反应，帕姆第一次放松下来。她脸上的表情变了，她看起来很开心。吉姆把车开过来并下了车。珍娜，我读到这里时心想，什么？
What would Pam ever tell her baby don't bust my balls and drink from my titay and shut your stupid mouth? I was like, what happened here? What happened? Lady, I couldn't do it. I couldn't do it. This was not in the table draft. This was a rewrite for the shooting draft.
帕姆怎么会对她的宝宝说“别跟我过不去”、“从我的胸部吸奶”以及“闭上你愚蠢的小嘴”这种话？当时我想，这里发生了什么？到底发生了什么？天哪，我演不下去。我演不下去。这不在台本初稿里。这是为拍摄剧本重写的。
On the day I talked to Charlie Granady, the writer, Paul Lieberstein, our showrunner at the time, and Harold Ramis. I said I cannot wrap my head around these lines. I mean, clearly they were trying to have a comedy moment, right? Yes. But the language is so foreign to something Pam would do with a brand new newborn baby.
那天我跟编剧查理·格兰迪、我们当时的运作人保罗·李伯斯坦以及哈罗德·雷米斯谈了谈。我说我无法理解这些台词。我的意思是，很显然他们是想制造一个喜剧效果，对吧？是的。但这些语言跟帕姆对一个刚出生的新生儿会说的话相差太远了。
Yeah. I mean, I said we've never seen Pam click into this kind of like, I don't know what kind of humor you call it. Kind of crass. Yeah. Is there a version of Pam we don't know because she looks around and makes sure the camera isn't there and then she's like, look at my titay.
我是说，我说我们从来没见过帕姆表现出这种，我不知道这叫什么幽默感。有点粗俗。对。难道有一个我们不了解的帕姆版本吗？因为她四处张望确保摄像机不在附近，然后她说，看看我的胸。
I don't know. What is this person? So we shot it even though I kept saying the two things that I really couldn't say were titay, which I had to say twice, and stupid little mouth. And I said I cannot look at this baby and say stupid little mouth. I can't do it. And they kept telling me that it was like charming and ironic
我不知道。这到底是个什么人？所以我们还是拍了，尽管我一直说我有两处台词实在说不出口，一处是胸（titay），我得说两次，另一处是愚蠢的小嘴。我说我看着这个宝宝说不出“愚蠢的小嘴”这种话。我做不到。但他们一直告诉我这很迷人、很讽刺，
and something that moms do that like moms are like, come on baby, let your stupid little mouth on my titay. Like that's what they were going for. They were going for like, she's either going to like start crying or she has to like be a weirdo. And I was like, I'm just, I can only approach this earnestly. That is who Pam is in her heart. Yeah.
而且是妈妈们会做的事，就像妈妈们会说，来吧，宝贝，把你的愚蠢小嘴含在我的胸上。这就是他们追求的效果。他们追求的效果是，要么她要开始哭了，要么她得表现得像个怪咖。而我说我只能真诚地去诠释。这才是帕姆内心深处的样子。对。
I don't believe it. It was a huge thing. So we shot it. They went to the editing room and it didn't work. Right. They saw that it didn't work. We shot this outside of the hospital, by the way, we shot this on the real bench outside of the real hospital
我不信。这是一件大事。所以我们拍了。他们去了剪辑室，结果发现行不通。没错。他们发现行不通。顺便说一句，我们是在医院外面拍的，我们在现实中那家医院外面的真实长椅上进行外景拍摄的。
on location. So when they realized that it didn't work, they wanted to do a reshoot. So they built a bench and like the exterior of the hospital on our warehouse set. This is the other set that I was saying was not really outside. And instead they went back to the table read draft, which just has Pam sitting there.
所以当他们意识到行不通时，他们想要补拍。于是他们在我们的仓库摄影棚里搭建了一个长椅和医院的外景。这就是我刚才说的那个并不是真的在室外的布景。相反，他们回到了剧本围读时的初稿，也就是帕姆只是坐在那里，
Like maybe she's on the verge of tears. And then it happens just as Jim walks up and then we know they're going to be okay. And my heart needed that scene. Yes. I didn't need a comedy moment here. I just needed them to be okay. Yeah.
就像她快要哭出来了那样。然后就在吉姆走过来时事情发生了，接着我们就知道他们会没事的。而我的内心需要那个场景。是的。我这里不需要一个喜剧时刻。我只是需要他们一切都好。对。
So when you're watching that scene, we are very carefully cutting back between the original shoot day and that reshoot day. I mean, I will just never forget that because that was... Tittay. I couldn't do it. Tittay. Stupid little mouth.
所以当你看到那个场景时，我们在最初的拍摄日和补拍日之间非常小心地剪辑切换。我的意思是，我永远不会忘记那是因为那是……胸部。我实在说不出口。胸部。愚蠢的小嘴。
I couldn't say it. Oh my gosh. Look at my tittays. Who is Pam? I don't know. Who is Pam in this moment? Anyway, that finishes out Jim and Pam's storyline, but we have to go back and talk about this very important facts
我真的说不出口。哦，天哪。看看我的胸。帕姆是谁？我不知道。帕姆在这个时刻到底是谁？不管怎样，吉姆和帕姆的故事线就到这里，但我们必须回头谈谈这个非常重要的事实，
that Andy is going to send to Erin. Oh, Erin. It's so sweet. The facts is Andy asking Erin out to dinner. I wanted to point out that at 20 minutes, 30 seconds, the facts cover sheet has a new logo that says, Dunder Mifflin, a division of Sabre. This is the only nod to Sabre or the Sabre storyline.
就是安迪要给艾琳发传真。哦，艾琳。太甜了。这个传真是安迪约艾琳共进晚餐。我想指出的是，在20分钟30秒时，传真封面有一个新标志，上面写着“邓德·米夫林，萨贝尔旗下部门”。这是整集中
In the whole episode. In both of the delivery episodes. All right. We've sort of not talked about Sabre, but there it is alive and well. Well, old tech alert. We have a fax machine, guys. Remember those?
唯一一次提到萨贝尔或萨贝尔的故事线。在两集产子特辑里都是如此。好吧。我们有点没怎么谈论萨贝尔，但它就在那里，生机勃勃。好吧，老旧科技警报。我们有个传真机，伙计们。还记得那些吗？
And Erin is trying to use it. The number keeps ringing busy. Yes, because she's faxing it to herself. I know, I know. And Andy didn't think about that part. He didn't. He said she's going to get fired if she doesn't do it and she just starts crying, bless her heart.
而艾琳正试图使用它。号码一直占线。是的，因为她把传真发给了她自己。我知道，我知道。而安迪根本没考虑到这一点。他没有。他说如果她不发就会被开除，然后她就直接哭了起来，愿上帝保佑她。
And then he's like, no, no, read it. Read it. And then finally. Yes. They're going to go on a date finally. And they're both so happy. We got some mail asking if Andy's line, it's a date, was a callback to Jim telling Pam it's a date from the job.
然后他说，不，不，读它。读它。然后终于。是的。他们终于要约会了。而且他们俩都超级高兴。我们收到了一些信件，询问安迪的台词“这算是一次约会”是不是在呼应吉姆在《工作》那一集中对帕姆说的“这算是一次约会”。
But writer Charlie Grandi said it was not intentional. It's just a coincidence. Oh, they were not trying to call anything back there. Michael's very pleased. He thinks he's done it again. Yeah. He says that there's just no greater feeling than when two people who are perfect for each other overcome all obstacles
但编剧查理·格兰迪说这不是刻意安排的。这只是个巧合。哦，他们并不是想呼应那里的任何东西。迈克尔非常高兴。他觉得自己又成功了。对。他说，当两个彼此完美契合的人克服所有阻碍并找到真爱时，没有比这更伟大的感觉了。
and find true love. But also the cigar is making him sick. Of course. Over at Jim and Pam's house, Isabel stops by with some macaroni. There's no fridge to put it in. But there is Dwight in a tank top, arm hair and all hanging out. I found rain kind of sexy in the scene. Well, so did Isabel.
但同时雪茄也让他很不舒服。当然。在吉姆和帕姆的家里，伊莎贝拉带着一些通心粉顺道拜访了。没有冰箱可以放。但是德怀特穿着一件背心，露着手臂上的汗毛，就晃悠在那里。我觉得雷恩在这个场景里挺性感的。嗯，伊莎贝拉也这么觉得。
Is that weird? Am I weird? What was it? This, I think, actually rain is an attractive man in real life when he is not being Dwight. And I think like this is your glimpse of the, I don't know, the pheromones that are rain. Well, rain has like a real sort of just self assurance.
这很奇怪吗？我很奇怪吗？那是什么？这个，我其实觉得雷恩在现实生活中，当他不是德怀特时，是个很有吸引力的男人。我觉得这就像是你难得一窥，我不知道，雷恩身上散发出的费洛蒙。嗯，雷恩有一种真正的、那种自信。
And I think it's attractive. And I think Isabel picks up on that. Yeah. And it does end with Dwight and Angela getting their contract all in order. Yes. There's a lot of paperwork, a lot of identification checking. Okay.
而且我觉得这很有吸引力。我觉得伊莎贝拉注意到了这一点。对。而且最后德怀特和安吉拉确实把他们的合同安排得妥妥当当。是的。有很多文书工作，大量的身份核对。好吧。
I have a story about the scene. We were filming in the warehouse, you know, in the set that they built. We sit down to rehearse. On our table is like two stamps, stacks of papers, a contract, like so many props, right? Harold Ramis has us rehearse the scene one time. We're going through it. I'm stamping things.
我有个关于这个场景的故事。我们在仓库里拍戏，你知道的，在他们搭建的那个布景里。我们坐下来排练。我们的桌上有两个印章、一叠叠文件、一份合同，有超级多的道具，对吧？哈罗德·雷米斯让我们把这个场景排练了一次。我们过了一遍。我在盖章。
I'm checking off. And he looks up and goes, where is the, I wanted a money pouch. I had like a money pouch, like from a bank. And I wanted this other stamp and I wanted this certain pin. And I was like, rain, who are you? Carrot top? Look at all these props. How many more props do you need?
我在核对。然后他抬起头说，那个在哪里？我想要一个钱袋。我当时想要一个钱袋，就像银行用的那种。我还想要另一个印章，我想要这种特定的笔。然后我想，雷恩，你到底是谁？胡萝卜头？看看所有这些道具。你到底还需要多少道具？
And then Phil Shea came running in and Harold was so funny. Harold looked at me and kind of rolled his eyes and was like, he likes his props. I was like, he does. And we kind of had a moment where we gave rain a little shit for his love of props, but I hope they sold the scene. I hope when you watch it, you get how serious the two of them were taking this procreation contract.
然后菲尔·谢伊跑了进来，哈罗德太搞笑了。哈罗德看着我，翻了个白眼，然后说，他就是喜欢他的道具。我就想，他确实喜欢。我们当时还开玩笑，拿雷恩对道具的热爱调侃了一番，但我希望他们演出了那个场景。我希望你们在看的时候，能体会到他们两个把这份生子合同看得有多么严肃。
Angela's really excited to get started. I, you know, and it breaks my heart because Dwight is now fixated on Isabelle. I know it's flipped. He wanted her. She was mad at him. Now she wants him and he's giving up. He's moving on.
安吉拉真的很兴奋能开始。我，你知道的，这让我心碎，因为德怀特现在满脑子都是伊莎贝拉。我知道，情况反过来了。他以前想要她。她生他的气。现在她想要他，而他却要放弃了。他要向前看了。
I can't wait to see this storyline play out. It was a really fun storyline. Well, before we end this episode, we got this fan question from Anna W. In England, who wrote in to say, I'm a midwife from the UK. And my question is, do you think this is an accurate representation of what it's like to have a baby in the American healthcare system? I actually kind of felt sad that Pam is being rushed out of the
我迫不及待地想看这条故事线如何发展了。这真的是一条非常有趣的故事线。好吧，在我们结束这一集之前，我们收到了来自英国安娜·W的粉丝提问，她写道，我是来自英国的一名助产士。我的问题是，你们觉得这真实展现了在美国医疗系统生孩子的体验吗？我其实有点难过，帕姆被催着离开
hospital when she's clearly not happy with breastfeeding and latching yet. At the hospital where I work here in England, women are welcome to stay in the hospital for however long they need to, especially if they haven't established breastfeeding yet. In fact, we would encourage women to stay in the hospital an extra night to get more confident with feeding if they're not sure about latching.
医院时，她明显还不太适应母乳喂养和含乳。在英国我工作的这家医院，女性可以根据需要想在医院住多久就住多久，特别是如果她们还没建立好母乳喂养的话。事实上，如果她们对含乳还不确定，我们会鼓励女性在医院多住一晚，以增强喂养的信心。
We also don't have nurseries for babies to go to at night. Is that a normal thing to happen in American maternity hospitals? The babies just stay with the parents and us midwives help with feeding and changing at the bedside. I find the differences really interesting. Also, I once looked after a woman in labor who wanted to watch the office the whole time. It was my best work day ever.
我们晚上也没有供婴儿呆的婴儿室。在美国的妇产医院，这也是正常现象吗？婴儿就跟父母呆在一起，而我们助产士则在病床边协助喂养和换尿布。我觉得这些差异真的很有趣。另外，我曾经照顾过一个在分娩期间一直想看《办公室》的产妇。那是我职业生涯中最棒的工作日。
I delivered her baby while the episode survivor man was playing. Oh my gosh, there's so much here. Diana, thank you so much for sending in that question. I will tell you, I've had several women tell me they gave birth while watching the office. I hear that too. Yeah. We kind of touched on this a little bit last week because we
我在播放“荒岛求生”那一集的时候帮她接生了宝宝。哦，天哪，这里有太多的内容了。戴安娜，非常感谢你发来这个问题。我告诉你们，有几位女性告诉我，她们是在看《办公室》的时候生孩子的。我也听到过这种说法。对。我们上周稍微提及过这个，因为我们
got similar questions about the American healthcare system only allowing a certain few nights in the hospital. Right. It's why Pam was trying to wait till midnight. Right. You know, my memory is that you only had a few days and then they wanted that room. Yes. If you have a vaginal birth, you get so many days.
收到了关于美国医疗系统只允许在医院住特定几晚的类似问题。对。这就是为什么帕姆试图撑到午夜。对。你知道的，我的记忆是，你只能住几天然后他们就想要那张床。是的。如果你是顺产，你可以住几天。
And if you have a C-section birth, you get an extra day. Yeah. But then you're out of there. You're out. I read this interesting article in The Atlantic and it was titled The High Cost of Having a Baby in America. It was written by Olga Kazan and I found it really interesting. I thought I would share.
如果你是剖腹产，可以多住一天。对。但之后你就得走人了。你得离开。我读过《大西洋月刊》上一篇很有意思的文章，标题是《在美国生孩子的沉重代价》。作者是奥尔加·卡赞（Olga Kazan），我觉得非常有趣，所以想分享一下。
I'd love it. It was written in 2019. Here's what it says. The average delivery cost in America now costs more than $4,500, where, for example, in Finland, you pay less than $60 to have a baby. But in the U.S., the average new mother with insurance will pay more than $4,500 for labor and delivery.
我很乐意听。这篇文章写于2019年。它是这样说的：如今在美国，平均分娩成本超过4500美元，而在芬兰等地，生孩子的费用不到60美元。但在美国，有保险的平均新妈妈在分娩和接生上的花销就要超过4500美元。
For this study, researchers at the University of Michigan looked at over 600,000 American women who had health insurance through their jobs and gave birth between 2008 and 2015. They analyzed the insurance claims data for the cost of all the treatments and services the women used during the year prior to their delivery and during the delivery itself and for three months after to really get an accurate number. Well, I'm really glad they did that because there are a lot
在这项研究中，密歇根大学的研究人员调查了60万名通过工作获得医疗保险并在2008年至2015年期间生孩子的美国女性。他们分析了保险理赔数据，包括这些女性在分娩前一年、分娩当时以及分娩后三个月内使用的所有治疗和服务的费用，以得出真正准确的数字。嗯，我很高兴他们这样做了，因为有很多
of postnatal doctor visits that you go to after you've given birth and especially if you've had a C-section. And I'm sure that those have copays and other fees. So I'm glad they included that in the cost. Right, the three months after having a baby. Yes. The article goes on to say the high cost of bearing children, in part, also helps explain why the United States has one
产后医生复诊，都是在你生完孩子之后去看的，特别是如果你剖腹产的话。我确信这些都有共同支付（copay）和其他费用。所以我很高兴他们把这些计算在成本里。没错，生完孩子后的三个月。是的。文章接着指出，生育子女的高昂成本，在一定程度上也解释了为什么美国拥有发达国家中最高的
of the highest maternal mortality rates in the developed world. I didn't know that. Yep. When women worry about paying for their labor expenses, they might delay or miss certain elements of their prenatal or postpartum care. It also helps explain why American women are having babies at a record low rate.
孕产妇死亡率之一。我不知道这一点。是的。当女性担心无力支付分娩费用时，她们可能会推迟或错过孕期或产后护理的某些环节。这也解释了为什么美国女性的生育率正处于历史最低点。
There are many things that factor into this low birthing rate, but it says that it certainly doesn't help that having a baby costs more than the median average woman earns in a month. Some women in fact might literally not be able to afford to get pregnant. You know, another cost that they're not talking about there is the cost of taking off work after you've had your baby. When I had my son and I was working on the office,
导致生育率低下的因素有很多，但文章称，生孩子的花销超过了一个普通女性一个月的收入中位数，这绝对无济于事。事实上，有些女性可能真的负担不起怀孕的费用。你知道，他们没有提到的另一个成本是在生完孩子后请假不工作的成本。当我生下儿子并在办公室工作时，
I had no paid maternity leave and the show did not go on any kind of break. We kind of talked about this in our book. Yeah. That even though the show had gone on breaks for other cast members to do movies, it did not take a break when I had my baby. Right.
我没有带薪产假，节目也没有停播休息。我们在书里也聊过这个。是的。尽管为了其他演员去拍电影，节目曾暂停过，但当我生孩子时，节目并没有停播。没错。
So I lost a quarter of my salary that year because I couldn't be in those episodes right after I gave birth. So I guess you could add that to the cost of having a baby too, in addition to the medical bills. Yeah. Well, the article is really, really interesting. You know, we have a long way to go. We sure do.
所以我那年损失了四分之一的薪水，因为在我生完孩子后无法立即出演那些剧集。所以我想除了医疗账单之外，你也可以把这个加到生孩子的成本里。是的。嗯，这篇文章真的非常非常有趣。你知道，我们还有很长的路要走。确实如此。
We do. That's the truth. Yeah. Well, I thought we could end on this letter, Angela. This is from Ali in Atlanta, Georgia, who said, I thought this would be an appropriate episode to share my appreciation of how office ladies has touched my life. I had my first baby in November 2019
确实。千真万确。是的。嗯，我想我们可以用这封信来收尾，安吉拉。这是来自佐治亚州亚特兰大的阿里（Ali）写给我们的，她说：我认为这是一个合适的剧集，可以借此表达我对《办公室女孩》如何触动我人生的感激之情。我在2019年11月迎来了我的第一个孩子，
and during late nights nursing, the office was always on as my constant companion. Then COVID hit and I was isolated at home with my new baby. I quickly found office ladies the podcast and the two of you became my closest friends during my struggle with postpartum depression and anxiety. I really appreciate how this episode shows the real struggles of new parents.
在深夜哺乳时，《办公室》一直作为我的忠实伙伴播放。接着疫情爆发了，我孤零零地带着新出生的孩子被隔离在家。我很快发现了播客《办公室女孩》，你们两个在我与产后抑郁和焦虑抗争的日子里成了我最亲密的朋友。我真的很感激这一集展现了新手父母真实的挣扎。
I'm now seven months pregnant with my second baby and still listening to you two regularly as I prepare for our new edition. Thank you for being a bright light during my own journey of motherhood. And as a side note, one in five women experienced postpartum mood or anxiety disorders.
我现在怀着第二个孩子已经七个月了，在为我们的新成员做准备的同时，依然经常听你们俩的节目。感谢你们在我自己的为人母之旅中成为一束明亮的光。顺便提一下，五分之一的女性经历过产后情绪或焦虑障，
Just wanted to say that. Thank you for all you do to inspire and be there for women. Ali, thank you so much for sharing that. Ali, I am so glad that we have been able to be with you during this journey. Yeah. And I can't imagine what it must have been like to be home with a newborn during COVID.
我只想说这些。感谢你们为激励女性并陪伴在她们身边所做的一切。阿里，非常感谢你分享这些。阿里，我很高兴我们能在这个旅程中一直陪伴着你。是的。我无法想象在疫情期间独自在家带着新生儿会是什么样的体验。
It is already such an isolating time. It really is and to not be able to see family or have people stop by or have a community there with you. It must have been very lonely. We love you. We love you and we're so excited for you and we wish you all the best. And congratulations with your new baby.
那已经是一个极其孤立的时期了。确实如此，无法见到家人，无法让人顺便来看看，或者身边没有一个社群支持。那一定非常孤独。我们爱你。我们爱你，为你感到无比兴奋，并祝你一切顺利。祝贺你喜得贵子。
Yes. Well, I think we did it, Ange. That's the delivery part too. Pam and Jim and little CC makes three. By the way, at the very end of the episode, they walk in and they see the destruction. That's right. Dwight has been doing and they're just like,
是的。嗯，我想我们做到了，安吉。分娩部分也完成了。帕姆、吉姆和小西西（Cece）凑成三口之家。顺便说一句，在这一集的最后，他们走进去看到了满目疮痍。没错。德怀特搞出的破坏，他们当时就觉得，
they can't even deal with it. And on the commentary, they just mentioned like, they're just new parents with this newborn and they're finally home and they're just like, whatever. Yes. Well, a big thank you to Randy Cordray, to my sister, Emily, to Brian Baumgartner and to my husband, Lee Kirk.
他们甚至无法应对。在评论中，他们只是提到，就像他们是带着这个新生儿的新手父母，终于回到了家，然后他们就觉得，管他呢。是的。嗯，非常感谢兰迪·科德雷（Randy Cordray）、我的妹妹埃米利（Emily）、布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳（Brian Baumgartner）以及我的丈夫李·柯克（Lee Kirk）。
That's right. What a fun episode you guys, thanks for listening and we'll see you next week for St. Patrick's Day. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins.
没错。真是搞笑的一集，大家，谢谢你们的收听，我们下周圣帕特里克节见。感谢收听《办公室女孩》。《办公室女孩》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fischer）和安吉拉·金西（Angela Kinsey）制作。我们的节目由科迪·费舍尔（Cody Fisher）执行制作。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯（Cassie Jerkins）。
Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubaco. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com for a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium. Use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗（Sam Kiefer），我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·巴巴科（Ainsley Bubaco）。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿（Creed Bratton）的《Rubber Tree》。要收听《办公室女孩》的无广告版本，请访问StitcherPremium.com免费试用Stitcher Premium一个月。使用代码：OFFICE。这一集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。